because the speed of the events
and the enormity
of the challenges
are sometimes very difficult to grasp
and this has also been a time of soul
searching
people are re-evaluating their own lives
we are having wider debates on shared
vaccines and shared values
but as i look back on this past year
and if i look at the state of the union
today i see a strong soul in everything
what we do
it was robert schumann
who said
europe needs a soul
an ideal
and the political will to serve this
ideal
and europe has brought those words to
life in the last 12 months
in the biggest global health crisis for
a century
we chose to go it together so that every
part of europe had access to the
life-saving vaccines
in the deepest global economic crisis
for decades
we chose to go it together
with next generation eu
and in the gravest planetary crisis of
all time again
we chose to go it together
with the european green deal
we did it together as a commission
and i think from the bottom of my heart
my outstanding college of commissioners
for the enormous support during that
time
we did it together
as a parliament with 27 member states as
one europe and i think we can be proud
of it
[Applause]
but corona times are not over
and there is still
much grief in our society as the
pandemic lingers
there are hearts
we can never mend
life stories we can never finish
and time we can never give back
to our young
we face new and enduring challenges in
the world recovering and fracturing
unevenly
so there is no question
the next year will be another test of
character
but i believe
it is when you are tested
that your spirit
your soul truly shines through
and as i look across our union
i know that europe will pass the test
and what gives me that confidence
is the inspiration we can draw from
europe's young people
because our youth put meaning
into empathy
and solidarity
they believe we have a responsibility
towards the planet
and while they are anxious about the
future
they are determined to make it better
our union will be stronger
if it is more like our next generation
reflective
determined
and caring
grounded in values
and bold in action
and this spirit will be more important
than ever over the next 12 months
this is the message in the letter of
intent i sent this morning to president
sasali and prime minister janza to
outline our priorities for the year
ahead
honorable members
a year is long in
at the time of pandemics
when i stood here in front of you 12
months ago i did not know when or even
if we could have a safe and effective
vaccine against covet 19.
but today
against all critics
europe is among the world leaders
more than 70 percent of our adult
population is fully vaccinated
we were the only ones
to share
half of our vaccine production with the
rest of the world we delivered more than
700 million doses of vaccines to the
europeans
we delivered
indeed we delivered also more than 700
million to the rest of the world to more
than 130 countries
and we are the only region in the world
to achieve that
honorable members a pandemic is a
marathon it's not a sprint
we follow the science we deliver to
europe we deliver to the rest of the
world we did it the right way because we
did it the european way and i think it
worked
but why we have every reason to be
confident
we have no reason to be complacent
our first and most urgent priority is to
speed up global vaccination
with less than one percent of global
doses administered in low-income
countries
the scale of injustice and the level of
urgency
is obvious
this is one of the great geopolitic
issues in our time
team europe is investing 1 billion euro
to ramp up mrna production capacity with
africa
we have already committed to share 250
million doses of vaccine i can announce
today
that the commission
will add a new donation
of another 200 million doses until the
middle of next year
this is an investment in solidarity and
it is an investment also in global
health
the second priority
is to continue our efforts here in
europe
we see worrisome divergences between
member states what vaccination rates are
concerned
so we need to keep up the momentum and
europe is ready
we have 1.8 billion additional doses
secured this is enough for us and our
neighborhood when booster shots are
needed
so let's do everything possible
that this does not turn into a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
and my third point
the final priority is to strengthen
our pandemic preparedness
last year
i said it was time to build a european
health union
today we are delivering
with our proposal we get the hera
authority up and running
this will be a huge asset to deal with
future health threats
earlier and better
we have the innovation and scientific
capacity we have the private sector
knowledge we have competent national
authorities
and now we have to bring all that
together including
massive funding
so i am proposing a new health
preparedness and resilience mission
for the whole of the european union
and it should be backed up
by team europe investment of 50 billion
by 2027
to make sure
that no virus will ever turn
a local epidemic again in a global
pandemic there is no better return on
investment than that
honorable members
the work on the european health union is
a big step forward
and i want to thank this house
for your support
we have shown
that when we act together we can act
fast
take the eu digital certificate
today more than 400 million certificates
have been generated across europe
42 countries
in four different continents are plugged
in
we proposed it in march you pushed hard
you helped enormously three months later
three months later only it was up and
running so while the rest of the world
was talking about europe just did it
and we did a lot of things right
we moved fast to creature
this supported over 31 billion million
workers and 2.5 million companies across
europe
we learned the lessons from the past
when we were too divided
and too delayed
and the difference is stuck
last time it took us eight years for the
eurozone gdp to get back to pre-crisis
level
this time
we expect 19 countries to be at
pre-pandemic levels this year
with the rest following next
growth in the euro area outpaced both
the us
and china
in the last quarter but this is only the
beginning
and the lessons from the financial
crisis could serve as a cautionary tale
at that time europe declared victory too
soon
and we paid the price for that
and we will not repeat that mistake
the good news is
that with next generation eu
we will both invest in short-term
recovery
and in the long-term prosperity
we will address structural issues in our
economy from labor market reforms in
spain to pension reforms in slovenia or
to tax reforms in austria for example
in an unprecedented manner
we will invest in 5g and fiber
but equally important is the investment
in digital skills this is such an
important topic this task needs leaders
attention and it needs a structured
dialogue at top level we really have to
emphasize that and put a strong focus on
it
our response provides a clear direction
to market
and investors alike
but as we look ahead
we also need to reflect on how
the crisis has affected
the shape of our economy
from increased debts
to uneven impact on different sectors
on new ways of working
and to do that
the commission will relaunch the
discussion
on the economic governance review in the
coming weeks
the aim is
to build a consensus on the way forward
well ahead of 2023
honourable members
we will soon celebrate
30 years of single market
for 30 years it has been the great
enabler of progress
and prosperity in europe
at the outset of the pandemic
we had to defend it
against the pressures of erosion and
fragmentation
for our recovery
the single market is the driver of good
jobs and competitiveness
and that is particularly important in
the digital single market
we have made ambitious proposals in the
last year
for example to contain the gatekeeper
power of the major platforms
to underpin their democratic
responsibilities of those platforms
to foster innovation to channel the
power of artificial intelligence
digital is the make or break
issue and member states also share that
view for example if you look at the
digital spending in next generation eu
and you know we have a 20 target
we will even overshoot that 20
target that is good
that reflects the importance and of
investing in our european tech
sovereignty
but allow me to focus on semiconductors
for a moment
these tiny chips that make everything
work
from smartphones
to electric scooters from trains
to entire smart factories
there is no digital without those chips
and while we speak
whole production lines are already
working at reduced speed speed despite
growing demand
because of a shortage of semiconductors
and while global demand has exploded
europe's share across the entire value
chain
from the design of manufacturing
capacities
has shrunk
we depend right now on state-of-the-art
ships manufactured by asia
so this is not just a matter of our
competitiveness
this is also a matter of tax sovereignty
so let's put all our forces in it to
improve this situation
we will present a new european chips act
we need to link together
a world-class research design and
testing capacities
we need to coordinate the european level
and the national investment along the
value chain
and the aim is to jointly create a
state-of-the-art european chip ecosystem
including production
that ensures our security of supply
and will develop new markets for ground
breaking european tech
and yes i know this is a daunting task
without any questions a big big goal
that i put out there and i know there
are some now that claim it cannot be
done
but they have that said the same 20
years ago about galileo galileo
and now look where we are
we got our act together
today europe's satellite provide the
navigation system for more than two
billion smartphones worldwide
so we did it once we are world leaders
in galileo now let's be bold again and
let's focus all our forces on the
semiconductors and let's go and be a
world leader again this should be our
aim
ladies and gentlemen honorable members
the pandemic has left deep scars
with an enormous impact on our social
market economy
evening after evening
we all stood
at our windows in our doorways to
applaud the work of
the frontline workers
we all felt how much we depended on
their work how much we depended on the
work of those men and women who
uh devote their efforts on a low salary
with uh
insecure jobs
to our health so the applause might have
died down but i think the force of our
appreciation should continue and that is
why the implementation of the european
pillar of social rights is so important
we are talking about decent work
creating fair working conditions
better health care
and
striking the right
work-life balance if the pandemic has
taught us one thing it is the value of
our time
and there is no time more precious
than the time we spend
with those close to us
with our friends and family so this is
why we are promoting a new european
health strategy health care strategy to
ensure that every man and woman woman
can benefit from the best possible care
and find the right
work-life balance
but ladies and gentlemen
social justice
is not just a question of time
it is also a question of tax fairness
in our social market economy it is a
good thing for businesses to make
profits but if they make profits it is
thanks to the quality of our
infrastructure of our social security
systems of our education systems
so
the least that we can expect is that the
businesses should make their fair
contribution
[Applause]
and that is why we will continue to
fight against tax fraud and tax evasion
we
are going to
propose a legal act to try to get at the
profits hidden behind
false companies
store companies and we want to mobilize
efforts to achieve a worldwide and
minimum
corporate tax
to pay a fair amount of tax is not just
a question of ensuring proper public
finances but it is quite simply a
question of fairness and justice
ladies and gentlemen
we have all benefited from the
foundations of our european social
market economy
and therefore we have to ensure that the
next generation can also build on those
foundations
their future
we
have a highly educated young generation
a highly talented younger generation and
one full of motivation
we we have a generation a new generation
that has had to sacrifice so much
in order to protect the safety of others
usually
when you're young is the time to expand
your horizons make new experiences make
friends for life find your path in life
but what have we been asking what are we
asking of young people today we are
asking them to observe social distancing
measures we are asking them to stay at
home
to study at home
and we've asked them to do this for more
than a year
so that's why everything that we're
doing the the green uh
deal next generation eu aims to protect
the future of those young people that is
why the next generation
must
be funded by new owned resources which
we are working on at the moment
but we also have to ensure that we don't
create new rifts
because
europe needs all its young people
we have to encourage those who are
falling through the gaps in the net
those people who do not have a job those
people who are neither in education or
training
for those young people we want to offer
a new program alma
alma will offer young people
the possibility to get some
temporary work experience in another
member state
because they too
have the right to have an experience
like
erasmus to gain skills and experience to
create
links and to forge a new european
identity
but
if we want to redesign our union in
their image
young people also should be able to
shape the future of europe
europe should have a soul and a vision
that speaks to those young people as
jacques de la called for when he said
how can we
build europe if young people do not see
it as a collective project as a project
that reflects their future
and this is why
we
will propose
to make twenty twenty two
the year of european youth
faison
let's have a year devoted to
putting the spotlight on these young
people who have given up so much to
others
and young people should be leading the
debate in the conference on the future
of the of europe because it's their
future and it should be their conference
and as we have said
at the beginning of our mandate
the commission
is ready
to follow through on points decided by
the conference
this is a generation with a conscience
they are pushing us to go further and
faster
to tackle the climate crisis
and the events of the summer only served
to explain why
we saw floods in belgium and germany
and wildfires burning from greek to the
hills in france
and if we don't believe our own eyes we
only have to follow the science
the united nations recently published an
ipcc report the intergovernmental panel
on climate change
it is the authority
on the science of climate change
the report leaves no doubt
climate change
is only man made
but since it is man-made we can do
something about it
as i heard it say
it's warming it's us
we're sure
it's bad
but we can fix it
and change is already happening
more electric vehicles than diesel cars
were registered in germany in the first
half of this year
poland is now the eu's largest exporter
of batteries and electric buses
or take the new european bauhaus
that led to an explosion of creativity
of architects designers engineers across
our union
and if the european green deal has a
soul
then it is the new european bauhaus
so clearly something is on the move
and this is what the european green deal
is all about
in my speech last year i announced our
target of at least 55
emission reduction by 2030.
since then
we have together
turned our climate goals into legal
obligations
and we are the first major economy
to present comprehensive legislation in
order to get it done
you've seen the complexity of the detail
but the goal is simple
we will put a price on pollution
we will clean the energy we use
we will have smarter cars
and cleaner airplanes
and we will make sure
that higher climate ambition
comes with more social ambition
because this must be a fair green
transition
and this is why we propose the new
social climate fund
to tackle the energy poverty
that already 34 million europeans suffer
from
so i count on both
parliament
and member states to keep the package
and to keep the ambition together
when it comes to climate change and the
nature crisis
europe can do a lot
and it will support others
i am proud to announce today
that the european union will double its
external funding for biodiversity in
particular for the most vulnerable
countries
but europe cannot do it alone
the cop 26 in glasgow will be a moment
of truth for the global community
major economies from the us to japan
have set ambitions for climate
neutrality in 2050 or shortly after
that's good
but they need now to be backed up by
concrete plans in time for glasgow
because current commitments for 2030
will not keep global warming at 1.5
celsius within reach
every country has a responsibility
the goals that president xi has set out
for china are encouraging
but we call for that same leadership
on setting out how china will get there
the world would be relieved if they
showed they could peak emissions by
mid-decade and move away from coal at
home and abroad
but while every country
has a responsibility
major economies like us
do have a special duty
to the least developed
and the most vulnerable countries
the so-called climate finance
is essential for them
both for mitigation
and adaptation
in mexico and in paris
the major economies committed to provide
100 billion dollars a year until 2025
to the least developed and most
vulnerable countries
we deliver on our commitments
team europe contributes 25 billion
dollars a year
but others still leave a gaping hole
towards reaching the global target
so closing that gap
will increase the chance of success in
glasgow
my message today is
that europe is ready to do more
we will now propose an additional 4
billion euro
for climate finance until 2027
but we expect the united states and our
partners to step up too
this is vital because closing the
climate finance gap together the us and
the european union would be such a
strong signal for global climate
leadership and it is time to deliver now
we have no time to wait anymore
honorable members
this climate and economic leadership
is central to europe's global and
security objectives
it also reflects a wider shift in world
affairs at a time of transition
towards a new international order
we are entering a new era
of hyper competitiveness
an era in which some stop at nothing
to gain influence from vaccine promises
to high interest loans from missiles to
misinformation
an era of regional rivalries and major
powers refocusing their attention
towards each other
recent events in afghanistan
are not the cause of this change
but they are a symptom of it
and first and foremost i want to be
clear
we stand by the afghan people
we stand by the afghan people the women
and children prosecutors journalists and
human rights defenders
i think in particular of women judges
who are now in hiding from the men they
jailed
they have been put at risk for their
contribution to justice
and the rule of law
we must support them and we will
coordinate all efforts with member
states to bring them to safety
and we must continue supporting all
afghans in the country and in
neighboring countries
we must do everything to avert the real
risk that is out there of a major famine
and a humanitarian disaster
and we will do our part
we will increase again
humanitarian aid for afghanistan by 100
million euro
this will be part of a new
wider afghan support package
that we will present in the next weeks
to combine all our efforts
honorable members
witnessing and events unfold in
afghanistan
was profoundly painful
for the families and friends
of fallen servicemen and service women
we bow
to the sacrifice
of those soldiers diplomats and aid
workers
who laid down their lives for our common
cause
to make sure that their service will
never be in vain
we have to reflect on how this mission
could end so abruptly
they are deeply troubling questions that
allies will have to tackle within nato
but there's simply no security and
defense issue
where less
cooperation is the answer so we need to
invest in our joint partnership and draw
on each side's unique strength
and this is why we are working with
secretary general jens stoltenberg
on a new eu nato joint declaration to be
presented before the end of the year
but
this is only one part
of the equation
europe can
and clearly should
be able and willing
to do more on its own
but if we are to do more
we first need to explain why
i see three broad categories
first
we need to provide stability in our
neighborhood
and across different regions
we are connected to the world by narrow
straits stormy seas and vast land
borders
and because of that geography
europe knows better than anyone else
that if you don't deal in time with a
crisis abroad
this crisis will come to you
secondly the nature of the threats we
face
is evolving rapidly
from hybrid to cyber attacks to the
growing arms race in space
we see that disruptive technology has
been the great equalizer in the way
power can be used today by rocks states
and non-state groups
you no longer need an army or missile to
cause mass damage
you can paralyze industrial plants city
administrations and hospitals
all you need is your laptop
you can disrupt
entire elections with a smartphone and
an internet connection
and the third reason is
that our european union is a unique
security provider
there will be missions
where nato or the united nations will
not be present
but where europe should be
on the ground our soldiers work side by
side with police officers lawyers and
doctors with humanitarian workers and
human rights defenders with teachers and
engineers
we can combine military and civilian
alongside with diplomatic and
development
and we have a long history
in building and protecting peace
the good news is that over the past
years we have started to develop kind of
a european defense ecosystem
but what we need now
is the european defense union
in the last weeks
there have been many discussions on
expeditionary forces
on what type and how many we need battle
groups and eu entry forces
this is no doubt part of the debate
and i think it will be part of the
solution
but the more fundamental issue is
why this has not worked in the past
you can have the most advanced forces in
the world but if you're never prepared
to use them of what use are they
what has has held us back until now
is not just a shortfall of capacity
it is the lack of political will
and if we develop this political will
there's a lot that we can do at eu level
allow me to give you three concrete
examples first
we need to build a foundation for
collective decision making and this is
what i call situational awareness
we fall short if member states active in
the same reason do not share their
information at the eu level
it is vital that we improve intelligence
cooperation but this is not just about
intelligence in the narrow sense
it is about bringing together
the knowledge from all services and all
sources from space
to police trainers from open source to
development agencies
the european union could have
a unique scope and depth of knowledge
it's out there
but we can only use that information and
make decisions
if we have the full picture and this is
currently not the case
we have the knowledge but it is disjoint
we have the information but it is
fragmented
and this is why
the european union could consider its
own
joint situational awareness center to
fuse all of these these different pieces
of information
and to be better prepared
to be fully informed and thus to be able
to decide
secondly
we need to improve interoperability
this is why we're already investing in
common european platforms from fighter
jets to drones and cybers you know that
but we have to keep thinking of new ways
to use all the possible synergies
one example could be
to consider waiving
value-added tax the vit
when buying defense equipment developed
and produced in
europe
this would not only increase our
interoperability
but it would also decrease
our dependencies of today
and the third point is
we cannot talk about defense without
talking about cyber
if everything is connected everything
can be hacked
and given that resources are scarce
scarce
we have to bundle our forces
and we should not just be satisfied
to address the cyber threat
but also strive to become a leader in
cyber security
it should be here in europe where cyber
defense tools are developed
and this is why we need a european cyber
defense policy including legislation on
common standards under a new european
cyber resilience act
so we can do a lot at eu level
but member states need to do more too
and this starts with a common assessment
of the threats we face
and a common approach to dealing with
them
the upcoming strategic compass is the
key process to this discussion
and we need to decide
how we can use
all the possibilities that are already
in the treaty
and this is why under the french
presidency
president macron
and i will convene a summit on european
defense
honourable members it is time for europe
to step up to the next level
[Applause]
in a more contested world protecting our
interests is not only about defending
ourselves
it is also about forging strong and
reliable partnerships
this is not a luxury it is essential for
our future stability security and
prosperity
and this work starts by deepening our
partnership with our closest allies with
the united states we will develop our
new agenda for global change
from the new tech and technology council
to health security and sustainability
the european union and the united states
will always be stronger together
and of course the same goes for our
neighbors in the western balkan
before the end of the month
i will travel to the region to send a
strong signal of our commitment to the
accession process
we owe it to all those young people who
believe in a future in europe
and this is why we're ramping up our
support through our new investment and
economic plan
with around a third of the region's gdp
because on a remembrance investment in
the future of the western balkan is an
investment in the future of the european
union
and we will also continue investing in
our partnership in our neighborhood
from stepping up on engagement in the
eastern partnership to implementing the
new agenda of the mediterranean
and continuing to work on the different
aspects of our relationship to turkey
honourable members if europe is to
become
a more global player
it also needs to focus on the next
generation of partnerships
in this spirit
today's new eu indo-pacific strategy is
a milestone
it reflects the glowing importance of
the region to our prosperity and our
security
but it also reflects the fact
that autocratic regimes use it
to try to expand their influence
europe needs to be more active
and to be more present in the region so
we will work together to deepen trade
links
strengthen global supply chains and
develop new investment projects on the
green and digital technologies
this is a template
for how
europe can redesign
its model to connect the world
we're pretty good at financing roads
but it does not make any sense for
europe
if we build a perfect road between a
copper that is chinese copper mine that
is chinese owned and a harbor that is
chinese owned
so we have to get smarter when it comes
to this kind of investment
and this is why we will soon present our
new connectivity strategy
called global
gateway we will build global gateway
partnerships with countries around the
world
we want investment in quality
infrastructure
connecting people goods and services
around the world
we will take a values-based approach
offering transparency
and good governance to our partners
we want to create links
and not dependencies
and we know that this can work
since the summer the new underwater
fiber optic cable has connected brazil
to portugal
we will invest with africa to create a
market for green hydrogen that connects
the two shores of the mediterranean
we need a team global approach to make
global gateway happen
we will connect institutions and
investment banks and business community
and we will make this a priority for
regional summits starting with the next
eu africa summit
in february
we want to turn global gateway
into a trusted brand
around the world
and let me be very clear about one more
point
doing business around the world is good
global trade
around the world
that is good and necessary
but this can never ever be done
at the expense of people's dignity and
freedom
today
there are around 25 million people out
there who are threatened
or coerced into forced labor
we can never accept
that they are forced to make products
and that these products then end up for
sale here in shops in europe so we will
propose a ban on products on our market
that have been made by forced labor
because human rights are not for sale at
any price
and honorable members human beings are
not bargaining ships look at what
happened at our borders with belarus
the regime in minsk has instrumentalized
human beings
they have put people on planes and
literally pushed them towards europe's
border this can never be tolerated and
the quick european reaction shows that
and rest assured we will continue to
stand together with lithuania latvia in
poland and let's call it what it is it
is a hybrid attack to destabilize europe
we'll never tolerate that
these are not isolated events we saw
similar incidents at other borders and
we can expect to see it again
and this is why as part of our work on
schengen
we will set out new ways
to respond to such aggression
and ensure unity in protecting our
external borders
but as long as we do not find common
ground
on how to manage migration
our opponents will continue to target
this
meanwhile human traffickers continue to
exploit people through deadly routes
across the mediterranean
and these events show us that every
country has a stake in building a
european migration system
the new pact on migration and asylum
gives us everything we need
to manage the different types of
situations we face
all the elements are there this is a
balanced and humane system that works
for all member states in all
circumstances
we know that we can find common ground
but in the year since the commission
presented the pact
progress has been painfully slow
and i think this is the moment now
for european migration management policy
so i urge this house and the member
states to speed up the process
this ultimately comes down to a question
of trust
trust between member states
trust
for europeans that migration can be
managed
trust that europe will always live up
to its enduring duty
to the most vulnerable
and most in
need i know that there are many strongly
held views on migration in europe
but i believe the common ground is not
so far away
because if you ask most europeans
they would agree
that we should act to curb irregular
migration but they would also agree
that we have to act to provide a refuge
to those forced to flee
they would agree that we should return
those who have no right to stay
but they would also agree that we should
welcome those who come here legally and
make such a vital contribution to our
society and our economies
and we should all agree that the topic
of migration should never be used to
divide us
i am convinced
that there is a way
that europe can build trust amongst us
when it comes to migration
societies that are based on democracy
and common values
are based on solid foundations
they believe in people
and this makes it possible for new ideas
to emerge and to bring about change to
overcome injustice
trust based on these common values
is what brought our founding fathers and
mothers together after the second world
war and it's precisely these values that
brought together freedom fighters
who tore down the iron curtain more than
30 years ago they wanted democracy
they wanted
to
freely choose and vote for their
governments they wanted the rule of law
they wanted everyone to be equal before
the law
they wanted to put an end to state
espionage and
spying and combat corruption
they wanted
the freedom to be different from the
majority or as vaclav havel so
beautifully put it
they wanted
all of these wonderful
fantastic european values
this is all part of the new uh
humanitarian
and religious heritage of europe it's
part of what we are
and these values are now enshrined in
our european treaties
all of us have committed ourselves to
respecting these
when we became part of the european
union as free sovereign states we
undertook to defend these values
and
we will never fail in this determination
[Music]
our values are guaranteed by our legal
order and the judgments of the european
court of justice
protect and safeguard these and these
rulings these judgments are binding and
we will pay attention to these judgments
being observed in every single member
state of our union
because the protection of the rule of
law is not just a
a wonderful
aim it's daily hard work and daily
attempts at improvement
and
this is all uh
what we are striving for in europe and
one example of this are the judicial
reforms going on in malta and the uh
attempts to deal with corruption in
slovakia and as of
2022 the reports on the rule of law will
increasingly include specific and
concrete recommendations to member state
governments
nevertheless
there is cause for concern in some
member states and one thing is very
important to me in this connection
dialogue always comes first
but
dialogue is not an end in itself it has
to lead to something
and therefore
we are following a two-pronged approach
based on dialogue and determined action
and this is what we did last week
and we will continue to do this
because
the right to an independent judiciary
the right
for equal treatment for all before the
law
these are rights that people have to be
able to rely on throughout europe and
independently of whether they belong to
a majority or a minority that is the
soul of europe and this is what we have
to defend
[Applause]
and ladies and gentlemen honourable
members the european budget
is the future of the european union
expressed in figures and it too has to
be safeguarded we need to ensure that
every euro every cent
is spent as intended and on a legal
basis respecting the rule of law
investments that are going to benefit
our children in the future must not
disappear into
shadowy channels
corruption corruption doesn't just mean
stealing from the taxpayer corruption
doesn't just mean
putting off investors deterring
investment corruption means that
people with lots of money can buy all
sorts of favors and that
democratic rules and principles can be
undermined and when it comes to
protecting our budget
we will follow up every case with
everything in our power and we're going
to get going on this without further ado
ladies and gentlemen if we wish to
defend our values
well when we defend our values we are
defending our freedom
the freedom to be who you are
the freedom to say
what is in your head what you are
thinking about the freedom to love
who you want
but freedom also means
freedom from
fear during the pandemic too many women
were robbed of this freedom
it must have been a particularly
appalling time
for people who could not hide
anywhere who couldn't flee from their
torturers so we need to shed some light
in these dark corners we have to find
ways out of this suffering uh
people who abuse women have to be
brought before the law and these women
have to be able to live freely in
confidence so by the end of the year
by the end of the year we will come
forward with an act to fight violence
against women
we're talking about uh effective um
criminal uh
criminal law rules and um
in for law enforcement is about
everybody's dignity and the right to
justice which is part of europe's soul
that we will fight for
honourable members
finally
let us look at one particular
freedom
that brings together all others or gives
a voice to all others and that is
freedom of the media journalists are
coming under attack simply because they
are doing their jobs
some are threatened intimidated or
beaten up
others tragically murdered
in our european union
i'd like to name some names
daphne hariana galicia
jan kuciak
peter de fries
their stories may differ in the detail
but they have one thing in common
they
stood up and fought for our right to
information and that's what they died
for
information is a public good
we have to protect those people who are
creating transparency and that is our
journalists and this is why today we are
coming forward with a recommendation on
better protection
of journalists
and
we have to put a stop
to those people who are threatening
freedom of the media
media companies are not just any old
company their
independence is essential and this is
why europe needs a law that secures
that protection and the media protection
act will do that because if we are
defending the media we are also
defending our democracy
honourable members
strengthening schumann's european idea
that i invoked earlier is a continuous
work
and we should not hide away from our
inconsistencies
and imperfections
but im imperfect as we might be
our union is both
beautifully unique
and uniquely beautiful
it is a union where we strengthen our
individual liberty through the strength
of our community
a union shaped as much by our shared
history and values
as by our different cultures and
perspectives
it is a union
with a soul
trying to find the right words
to capture the essence of this feeling
is not easy
but it is easier when you borrow them
from someone who inspires you
and this is why
i have invited
a guest of honor
to be with us today
many of you might know her
a gold medalist from italy
who captured my heart this summer
but what you might not know is
that only in
april she was told her life was in peril
she went through surgery
she fought back
she recovered
and only
119 days after she left the hospital
she won paralympic gold honorable
members please join me in welcoming babe
video
baba has overcome so much
so young
her story is one of rising against all
of
of succeeding thanks to talent
tenacity
and unrelenting positivity
she is the image of her generation a
leader and advocate for the causes she
believes in
and she has managed to achieve all of
that
by living up to her belief that if it
seems impossible
then it can be done
impossibly
well if you said then you can do it
and this was the spirit of our european
founders and this is the spirit of
europe's next generation
so let's be inspired by babe and by all
the young people
who change our
perception of the possible
who show us that you can be
what you want to be
and that you can achieve whatever you
believe in
honorable members that is the soul of
europe
that is the future of europe let's make
it stronger viva europa
long live europe
thank you very much president wander
lyon i now invite the speakers on behalf
of the political group starting with the
european people's party group month fed
weber
vice president mitzola
president fonda line minister loga
dear colleagues the ladies and gentlemen
debating
the state of the union means today the
first focus on what the pandemic has
brought
not everything went well and smoothly
but all in all europe has managed
the crisis well
no other continent has developed a
vaccine
in a better quality
no other continent has a higher
vaccination rate
no other continent has shown more
solidarity and willingness to help each
other
and no other continent has provided
other parts of the world with more
vaccines than we have
all europe is proud of our every day's
heroes the doctors and nurses
researchers and many others and we thank
them for their contribution
the crisis dear friends began in china
in europe we found the solutions we can
be proud about what europeans achieved
in the past
dear colleagues when we
look now what is in front of us
then there are two main issues we are
emerging stronger from the crisis but
this crisis has caused and left deep
social and economic wounds many people
fear for their existence for their jobs
only if we create jobs
then we can secure our prosperity and we
can care about the weakest in our
society and we will defend the european
way of life
alongside the green deal
we are thinking as epp that now is also
time for a chops deal
and in addition to this after
afghanistan we
really need now a comment foreign and
defense policy joe biden is clear the us
is no longer a world police man
but where is europe russia and china are
just waiting to fill the vacuum and that
would be fatal for the future we would
wake up in a world in which we and also
our children will not want to live
that's based on these two points i want
to make very concrete proposals for what
do we have to do now
firstly
the rapid development of a vaccine was
only possible because the authorities
worked quickly during the approval
process that it was the
biotech founders told us
no blockades but this speed is what we
also need now in other fields of the
research sector
and in the investments for the climate
protection
with an immediate action plan
for cutting bureaucracies in the
european union we should work together
with all stakeholders to identify 300 eu
regulations that we will abolish or
simplify in the next 12 months
secondly
for the production of an electric car
dear friends
only half the number of employees
is needed many industrial jobs in the
european union are under threat new jobs
are urgently needed in today's european
union
international trade wars and is a job
machine
why not now to pick up this debate with
our american friends let us negotiate an
eu us trade emergency program on the
mobility sector on mechanical
engineering in the digital economy
as soon as possible as a first step for
a more broader comprehensive trade
agreement and only this
will be
and only this will be the way to
strengthen the western economy key
industrial sectors and together we can
protect ourselves against china the
european union and the us together
represent 50 percent of the global
economy together we can start a growth
machine
that benefits the whole world
dear friends the pandemic has shown us
how important the health sector is
the coming decade will bring a wave of
innovation in medicine we can beat
cancer
i want europe to create 10 million new
jobs
in the next four years is an immediate
innovation offensive in this field at
the beginning of the digitalization 20
years ago vs europeans overslept the
innovation on internet and jobs were
created in the us and in china
today neither the chinese nor the
americans are ahead with the coveted
vaccines but we are so let us use our
know-how right now
firstly defense
we and i fully welcome the initiatives
from wesley on the line today and also
the decision of the defense council in
louisiana but
what are we waiting for dear friends the
lisbon treaty gives us all options
if we want to create a reaction force so
let's do it and let's do it now
and fifthly dear friends
global responsibility
every day 15 000 people
sorry 15 000 children
die of hunger worldwide every day
the everyday horror
and we hardly speak about it
the weakest suffer most from the covet
crisis
that is why we must reallocate and free
up france dear friends like we do it in
afghanistan now
to invest
we need to stop the silent and daily
mass death on this world
and finally dear friends without law and
security the rest means nothing
that is why we stand for a robust
application of the rule of law mechanism
inside of the european union
but that is not enough cross-border tax
fraud money laundering and criminal
organizations mafia make its way through
our societies and the terrorist threat
is still high in europe we don't why
don't we finally transform europol not
into a real european fbi and the
european commission should present in
the next 12 months a legislative package
to strengthen security in the european
union with the founder line was clear
that we can lead the world with a green
deal i want to put on the table that we
have to have the same ambitions now for
new jobs
for our international responsibility and
for security let's do it thank you
thank you
thank you very much mr berber now for
the group of socialists and democrats
ira garcia perez
president
president
honourable members a year ago we were
holding the
debate on the state of the union in
exceptional circumstances
we
were considering major challenges
putting the break on
the pandemic
guaranteeing
the provision of vaccines historic
investments to mitigate the the economic
impact
social measures to make sure no one was
left behind while at the same time we
sought to strengthen our democracies
from attacks which undermine the rule of
law looking back we can
take stock of the position and and see a
positive picture 70 percent of our
people are vaccinated and the digital
certificate has allowed us to restore
one of the fundamental freedoms of our
union freedom of movement
we've adopted next generation eu and the
money is starting to flow through to
ordinary people to families and firms
within the social democratic family
we have consistently continued to stress
that these investments
have to be geared towards the future we
have to invest thinking in terms of a
more sustainable economic and social
model a true fact for sustainability the
climate legislation is an important
challenge if we're to achieve
climate neutrality before 2050
parliament managed to raise
our
greenhouse gas reduction target above 55
before 2030
and we'll ask
the
commission to be more ambitious and fit
for 55 because we can't be complacent
we've done a lot but but we're only
halfway there
one of the things
that still require creation is the
health union present for the line when
you presented your party guidelines at
the beginning of your turn you you
promised
a green social market economy
but
sadly that those three elements are far
from being imbalanced
undoubtedly environmental
sustainability is where the commission
has made
more progress with the whole artillery
legislation it's a team effort led by
vice president timmermans and that shows
that the collegiate approach works when
you bring together all the ideas and
energy of the members of the college of
commissioners what we socialists find
lacking is
legislation to protect biodiversity this
summer's fires have reminded us
how necessarily this is as as corny
managers
what we're concerned about is this
imbalance amongst the three pillars of
this new socio-economic model we want to
build
the model has to be resilient and make
sure we can maintain people's
well-being with social cohesion
and
more
we have to be able to cope with
a less stable geopolitical position
we have to strengthen the social climate
fund in your
report a year ago the commission said
that a resilient europe would emerge
sooner and stronger from any crisis
in pursuit of the un's
sustainable development goals
we mustn't forget
that
the goal of any policy has to be
well-being of people i don't think we've
done enough on that front the pandemic
has worsened the inequalities of an
unfair economic system the most
vulnerable sections of society have
suffered the most
and still are older people children
health and care staff
less
highly trained people migrants
and
as as ever they're being used as
scapegoats
for populist and xenophobic messaging
we need
to reform governance with indicators
taking account of human development
we need a true social pillar
the
porto social summit was
a first step forward but we need
clear goals to press ahead
and i want to underscore a fundamental
gender party you
you made a lot of points this morning
president from the line may i say on
behalf of my group that the commission's
announcements that you will come out
with a law against gender violence in
europe
is undoubtedly wonderful news
it's excellent for years now for years
and years we've been calling for this
european legislation to fight the the
greatest scourge that exists today
throughout the world and in europe women
are dying they're being murdered just
because they're women and we we cannot
stand by arms faulted when this happens
that may i say to you that i still can't
understand how in this house we can have
groups
who are not
prepared
to include
gender-based violence in the european
legal audit we're going to continue to
work to ensure that that does happen
it's our moral duty
and
when talking about moral duties
migration and asylum policy
is another urgent need
we can see what's going on in
afghanistan and we can see that europe
needs to speak with a single voice in
foreign policy let's be brave we have to
move beyond the rule of unanimity on
determining foreign policy
and the state of law is crucial europe
is made up of values the defense of the
rule of law we have to be firm the
commission has taken some steps but it
has to be bolder yet and the socialists
and
democrats
will be backing you in that
lastly if you look at the convulsions
that with which the 21st century has
started georges sampaio a great european
and a great socialist said he didn't
know what the world would look like in a
few years time he only hoped that as he
looked back he would see that we had
managed to preserve the values of
democracy fundamental rights
freedom and tolerance
he is no longer with us
but his struggle for those values is our
struggle
for today's europe and for future
generations thank you
thank you
thank you miss garcia perez
next is mr dachan cholos for renew
europe
madam president
we are now nearly halfway through our
mandate that the european electorate
conferred on us in 2019 and i have to
admit that i am impatient of course
you're right to recall the achievements
of the union during the pandemic a
historic
recovery plan we have to acknowledge and
a new role for europe in the field of
health but these achievements were often
forced on us by events and on issues
that solely depend on the force of will
alone i'm i don't see you
producing results all too often you're
engaging in diplomacy with council
instead of
policymaking with the european
parliament
take for example european values which
are the foundation of our union
a little bit pretty much everywhere in
europe we are seeing outbreaks of
illiberalism
judicial independence is being eroded
journalists murdered
minorities discriminated against these
outbreaks of liberalism need to be put
out madam president before the fire
spreads
and that is your responsibility and you
have the means to do so
for the moment i hear your words but i
don't see your deeds
and i don't see you for example using
the
rule of law protection mechanism that
the european parliament has called for
in order to protect our budget and to
stop financing these uh
illiberal uh
actions in europe you have to find the
political courage to make use of this
mechanism that's why we adopted it it's
been enforced for nearly a year now and
you haven't used it
and
if you don't find that courage madam we
will
remind you of your obligation to apply
european law by going to the court of
justice
madam president you are engaging in
diplomacy with council instead of policy
making with us and i think it's a
mistake
on the green agenda the green deal and
the
climate package that we discussed at
length yesterday but also on the
migratory package
the migration package on the digital
agenda you need our help to get council
to shift your role isn't just to make
proposals but it's also to get results
and it's only in this way that
it would be natural for people to trust
europe
and i'm impatient as well for you to
bring life to the slogan of the
geopolitical commission this is a
concept that you presented at the
beginning of your mandate and we really
want to see this being realized the
events in afghanistan remind us
how much we need a genuine vision about
our defense in all of this a complex
situation of the 21st century that you
so well outlined in your statement and
it also reminds us to
to what extent our strategic
autonomy and even our sovereignty
um are at stake we have to affirm these
so that never again will we find
ourselves at the mercy of decisions
taken in washington beijing or moscow
michel has realized how important this
issue is but i'm not quite sure if this
is the case for the geopolitical
commission
perhaps one
avenue to explore madam would be to take
the lead in the battle
to vaccinate
the part of the world that is not going
to be able to manage on its own of
course
we welcome that 70 percent of the adult
european population
is vaccinated in europe but how can we
do
how can we congratulate ourselves when
only three percent of the population in
africa has received just one dose
at least so
we wrote you last week to explain how
our budget could be used to speed up the
vaccination process in the poorest
countries that madam president
is an objective worthy of the
geopolitical commission
and to conclude last week
our group renew europe
proposed to all pro-european forces in
this house to enter into a coalition
contract a coalition contract to renew
europe for europe of values for a strong
europe in an unstable world and for a
europe that delivers results my question
to you madam is simple do you want to be
part of this coalition
mercy
mercy mr cholash
may see mr
thank you mr chalash now i'll give the
floor to philip lambert for the green
room
madam president ladies and gentlemen
the summer we've just been through is
meant that the european union has to
face up to its responsibilities on two
major areas first of all the
environmental reconversion we've seen
that on the other side of the planet
there are
ecological disasters and that reminds us
that it is is urgent with the most
recent ipcc report confirms this
and the worst fears are confirmed
we shouldn't be waiting until 2050 to
deal with climate upheaval we should be
doing it today here and now
we shouldn't voice these problems on
future generations we have to do
something now it's incumbent on us to do
that
and we have to use our economic and
political power as well as economic
power to do that let's accelerate the
implementation of this let's make sure
that the ends that we want to achieve in
the means to achieve them
be applied
better the olympic motto faster higher
stronger should be something to help us
achieve
helping the climate
we've seen the common agricultural
policy proposal is deaf and blind to the
social climate and biodiversity issues
so that's exactly what we should not be
doing do the right thing let's vote this
cap down
when it comes to the fit for 55
legislative package for carbon
neutrality we have to accelerate things
we have to raise the bar of ambition why
wait till 2032 yes 2032 to tax kerasine
kerosene
and why not have
an objective of cutting a reliance on
non-renewable energies
but we can see that
fossil fuels are receiving millions and
millions of public subsidy
to
every year
and the parliament wanted this to be
stopped immediately that whereas the
commission is taking half measures and
once have graduated progressive uh uh
exit from that but you have the cards in
your hand madam president it's a scandal
the whole credibility of the green deal
is at stake let's not forget the
environmental transition is
not just showing solidarity it's a
question of making sure that if it costs
more to produce sustainably and fairly
then let's help out with the tax systems
it's up to the commission and the
european union to
get out of this social and tax
competition which is infernal to
actually give ourselves the
means to achieve this
transformation and that's true when it
comes to taxing multinationals even the
imf says that we should be taxing
capital
and what about those who are still
reluctant to take action to help the
client because they're worried about
jobs and the economy well there are two
things we can look at that either we're
going to fail and there'll be no more
economy because we won't be able to live
on this planet as human beings or
we
achieve this and then the european union
has to be at the forefront of the
transition because that's where the
heart of our competitiveness will lie in
the future
otherwise we will be reduced to having
to buy up solutions that will help us
from the rest of the world uh after
having lost the leadership in the
digital domain the european union cannot
fail on the green revolution
let's move on to the second major area
of importance and that is making
european union a geopolitical actor
commensurate with its capacities its
ambitions following humiliations in
moscow ankara
hardly less subtle in beijing we've now
seen the most recent attack from
washington the afghanistan disaster
provoked by unilateral withdrawal from
by the americans have shown once again
that we're impotent as europeans
as you
madam president my thoughts go first and
foremost the afghans who have suffered
war for two generations are still now
under the iron rule of fundamental
islamism
their thoughts also go to all our
citizens on the ground whether they be
uniformed or not who've paid with their
lives or their health because there's
been a lack of strategic vision from
their leaders
this disaster at least should give us an
opportunity to leap forward because the
european union could become a major
european
a major world actor but we have to give
ourselves the resources to do that and
that means sharing sovereignty it's only
through uniting our vision and our
powers that we as europeans would be
able to uh have influence beyond our
borders as individuals our states even
the biggest amongst them will remain
dwarfs amongst the giant powers both
when it comes to politics and on the
military side of things now giving
ourselves a resources means that we need
to
bolster our economic priorities
reinforce our autonomy
as a union we need to realize that we're
linked to our suppliers and our trade
interests not to mention our energy
interests and xi jinping and vladimir
putin are only too well aware of that
now giving us ourselves the resources is
also to bolster our statute as a
standard setting power
when it comes to the digital area for
example we want to make sure that
surveillance systems are helping us and
not subjugating us
giving ourselves the resources means
that we need to invest both inside our
borders and outside our borders as well
because
we shouldn't allow our partners to feel
abandoned by the
european union and we have to make
advances against any strategic rivals
we have to
understand how can we defend human
rights democracy and the
rule of law if we cannot have them
respected within our own union
how can we get
commitments that are up to
scratch from the rest of the world on
the climate if we don't meet our
historic responsibilities
then finally giving ourselves the
resources about choosing dignity for the
for the human race
of course european union is not alone in
being responsible for those 85 million
people forcibly displaced around the
world but
there is a question of responsibility
when it comes to climate change when it
comes to exploiting resources when it
comes to maintaining ra oppressive
regimes in power around the world and
armed conflict so i was scandalized just
a week before kabul fell six member
states including mine had the indecency
to insist on ex expelling people to
afghanistan
and i'm still
scandalized today
madam president
that
the only concern of the 27 27-member
state seems to be avoiding that any
afghan asylum
asylum seekers come to
our european territory so let's not
trample underfoot our fundamental values
or pander to autocrats like erdogan we
will never be respected as a
geopolitical actor if we do that madam
president ladies and gentlemen at the
time of brexit we recalled again and
again that the british government could
not have its cake and eat it it's high
time to us as europeans to apply
that common sense to ourselves as well
to be a leader of ecological and energy
transition show solidarity a respected
actor in the world
is something within our reach as long as
we roll up our sleeves and give
ourselves the resources we need thank
you
mr lambert
thank you mr lambert and now to jurg
muythen on behalf of the identity and
democracy group
president of the commission
for
eu citizens we don't want soothing words
about the state of the union uh just
another example of which you've just
delivered us
if you look soberly
at what we've
done
it's just uh
an orgy of spending money uh
this green deal fit for 55 the recovery
fund
this just really means more
centralization and more absurd and
pointless subsidization for more red
tape and democracy and telling citizens
what to do and this is all being done
with the hard earned money of the
citizens through eu taxes and and
through uh
the eu raising money on the markets
which was not provided for in the eu
treaties for good reason
but uh
this is actually a de facto a socialist
approach but
saving europe is not enough you want to
save the world as well uh you want to uh
save the world's client climate uh what
hubris and you want to
build up europe again
as if it had been destroyed by the
pandemic that was the case in the second
world war but it's not the case now but
you don't seem to mind because you have
an insatiable desire to acquire more
power and more control over people's
lives
have you ever
thought
that the citizens of the eu
just want one thing from the eu
they want
to be left in peace
they want to keep their own heart and
income instead of handing it over to
this
money hungry
administration in brussels
instead of having it for their children
for their future
you're actually getting the most support
from the left side of this house but you
should realize that in germany
a government of
red socialists and green socialists is
uh in the offing
um
so that will just uh inspire you to
fill the flames of your spending orgy
that
when you talk about deals a deal would
imply um consenting parties uh what
you're doing is uh
an unparalleled attack against the
economic foundations of our continent so
europe is on its own going to save the
whole world and yet the price tag for
this incredible hubris is going to be
paid by the citizens
we've seen how ridiculous it is to be
getting out of
coal and nuclear all at the same time
the german citizens have
experienced this for themselves so
they've ended up with the highest energy
prices in europe thanks to angela
merkel's approach
people can can't afford to heat their
homes or buy fuel for their car on their
way to work this is not a very good
example for our neighboring countries
the green deal uh
colleagues is going to affect all of you
you're going to go through what we've
been through in germany madam president
uh you and
germany as well are
at a crossroads if you want europe to be
a prosperous flourishing continent and
at the same time achieve your objective
of massively reducing co2 emissions uh
you're not going to do this with some
kind of plant economy experiments by the
eu commission or with any kind of
pseudo-ecological projects by the greens
that will
build
wind farms all over our countryside
it won't work we're just going to have
blackouts and energy rationing
you're only going to solve these
problems through high tech and that
doesn't come from brussels high
technology
will only work as well if we make uh
modern use of
the latest generation of nuclear energy
so your whole plan is
completely wrong you are
literally leading the people of europe
into a cold and dark future literally
europe is not fit today europe is a sick
patient
and of course
it doesn't have the basic requirement
for recovery which is understanding what
its problem is
all of the covalent policy or the
catastrophic migration policy is all
going down the wrong track
you've
shown massive hubris and
self-satisfaction in your speech but
this is not going to serve the purposes
of the people of europe uh
in 25 years time madam i predict that
we will just look back and shake our
heads in despair at uh the
misguided policies that we're following
today and you know you don't need to
have a crystal ball you can just
understand that if you look at the
economic facts
[Applause]
at this point i give the floor to
rafael on behalf of the ecr
thank you president president of the
commission i listened very carefully
to your speech
and
i think it's important
given
the juncture which europe finds itself
to
shed light on what's been done you've
mentioned
next generation and the vaccination
campaign but it's also important to
grasp
europe's problems
by acknowledging
what has not worked
within the current european union
during the pandemic
given the uncertainty of of covert 19
there was a lack of solidarity unity
a selfish approach ensued and it took a
long time to to tackle the problem that
should be recognized
will we need to learn from this so that
we can make better use of opportunities
that arise
i see changes are required
our group as ever
is prepared to act not just with empty
slogans but palpable action
so that everyone's positions can be
respected
the pandemic
is still there the international context
is increasingly being characterized by
major
conflicts amongst a range of players
the new foci of instability opposing
challenges that's why our continent must
be in a position to respond
you mentioned
health in conjunction with
the associated economic
pillow
well
starch policy must
allow
for a solid economic recovery creating
jobs and social stability the resources
in next generation eu have an important
role but they're not enough on their own
i didn't hear a single word being said
about
the stability pact the elephant in the
room
nobody's talking about is if there's no
problem
but it's absolutely crucial
because if you change the mechanism
while respecting the the letter angels
will not solve the problem going back to
two years before as if nothing had
happened would be disastrous
and would would mean that the policies
referred to
would be
very lacking in credibility
after changes on state aid
that's lenting to increasing disparities
amongst member states
we're becoming increasingly
dependent on
third countries for strategic resources
now all this needs to be tackled
with environmental and digital
transition process of course we agree
with that
and we can't just put our backs to the
wall and
indulge
in
empty rhetoric
but you have to
assess the the general conditions around
the world and the impact on
our industry and our economy because
otherwise we will harm it
and we will not achieve the goals that
that we're all
looking to achieve
then the international issue of
migration is creating emergency you
talked about a migration pact
well there are three fronts here a very
different approach first of all there's
central europe
there there's hypocritical investment
resources then relations with turkey
nothing's being done in the
mediterranean though
migration is being used
for political advantage by lukashinka
as mentioned yes i will wind up
i think it's important
nasa to refer to the the rule of law
we are
prepared
to tackle this
we're not interested in a federalist uh
project emerging from the conference on
future europe
if you will respect the member states
that then we're on board
but
trying to translate particular mistakes
it's not compound
just shows that a majority is trying to
impose its views on the others and that
runs counter to the principles of a
union that should respect diversity and
the
competencies of the individual member
states
on behalf of the left group for martin
children
thank you madam president miss fonda
line you've
presented to us today a lot of
self-praise but unfortunately many
answers and above all a convincing idea
for a future development of the european
union were still missing
this parliament 140 former heads of
state and government
nobel prize winners around the world
more than a hundred states are asking
for the patent waiver for the corona
vaccine
because we've understood that the
pandemic can only truly be overcome
once the vaccine is available to
everybody including in the global south
when will the commission
give up its blockade to this waiver on
the vaccine
in order to protect
the health of all europeans and to avoid
the
further splitting
of our society
the 10 richest billionaires in europe
let me repeat those figures so you can
contemplate them the 10 richest
billionaires in europe during the
pandemic have increased their net wealth
by more than
180
billion euros at the same time one in
five children in the european union
lives in poverty
and
we know that the crisis has affect
affected lower skilled workers the
self-employed service providers in
precarious jobs they've lost their jobs
i don't want them all the southern
european youth or pensioners to have to
pay for this crisis
we should have a
minimum tax for multinational
companies which has teeth we have to
have a comprehensive financial
transaction tax that could garner 40
billion euros
for our coffers
tax justice and combating poverty go
hand in hand when are you finally going
to make both of these a priority of your
work in the commission ms fonda lion
in the west we find ourselves following
the
defeat of nato and afghanistan in a deep
crisis the policy of military
intervention and nation building has
disastrously failed and nevertheless mr
burrell the high representative is doing
nothing more than calling for more
armament and more military solutions mr
weber do you not think that the money
that you want to invest in the military
wouldn't be better spent on combating
poverty
the lessons from the disaster in
afghanistan cannot just be that the
european
union works on a sovereign
policy to work on developing policies
better uh develop
trade policy more effective climate
protection and humanitarian migration
policies that's how
we become a credible and strong actor in
international relations
ladies and gentlemen to overcome the
european
stalemate that we see in politics today
we need a new beginning here in this
chamber and to you social democrats and
greens you are well aware that your
ideas of better social security and more
effective climate protection are not
going to be
gained with the current majorities we
have in this chamber turning to the
liberals you are well aware that your
ideas of defending democracy fundamental
freedoms cannot be implemented if you
continue to have to form majorities with
those who cannot form clear borders to
the right of their political spectrum so
let us work together on new majorities
for social and climate justice for
digital transformation that leaves no
nobody behind and for the bolstering of
democracy that the europeans
well deserve thank you for your
attention mr sudevan
i now give the floor to tatiana begin by
remembering non-affiliation
i'm not attached to members
thank you president
president
colleagues who totally have to take
important decisions
for the future
generations the future lies in our hands
at the moment the five-star movement has
a proposal let's meet miss van der lion
and talk together conte who made a vital
contribution to the recovery fund
let's establish how the stability pact
can be turned into a solidarity and
development pact
we need sustainable development to save
the planet from the environmental
disaster we need technological
development to help our firms compete on
the world market and we need to develop
rights because in too many parts of
europe
they're being denied
and the commission
can propose amendments to the the budget
to reflect the
impact of the pandemic we need a new
pact to replace austerity with the word
solidarity
let's adopt a european minimum wage
let's strengthen our
common foreign and
security policy because
our citizens can see
our model
as one
to be followed by others
if if europe
had only half the
the the currency that that amazing um
champion had
then would be halfway to solving our
problems
honorable members
madam president of the commission
first of all on behalf of the council i
thank and congratulate
president vanderline for address a
strong and continued pro-european
conviction
and her action in this moment when the
eu is gradually recovering from the
pandemic
but facing great challenges in terms of
climate change and the international
situation
you underlined strong soul is needed
strong soul will be delivered from the
presidency side
we continue to be guided by the
strategic agenda 2019-2024
and in my view the slovenian presidency
priorities
fits perfectly well
with president from the line address
today
during our presidency we are focusing in
particularly on building up health and
cyber resilience and also highlighting
the need to ensure resilience to any
type of crisis
covet showed that in the time of crisis
internal market and the four freedoms
come very fragile
therefore i believe that further
strengthening of the single market must
stay in our focus and an unhindered
functioning of the internal market is of
key importance for the european economy
regarding the health union intensive
work between the council and the
european parliament is ongoing
the council is working towards achieving
final agreement on the three proposals
in the package by the end of the year we
certainly need to use this political
momentum and to show our citizens that
together we are building a more silent
union that will be better prepared to
cope with future health crisis
we are welcoming the hera proposal
published yesterday i can assure you
that the slovenian presidency will make
every effort to advance negotiation we
see the hera proposal in complementary
with the health union package ladies and
gentlemen let me use this opportunity to
thank the european commission for a
strong leadership in the past year that
brought us to a point where a successful
vaccine rollout has contributed to a
stabilization of the epidemiological
situation nonetheless due to the vaccine
hesitancy in many countries as well as
the threat of variants we will need to
remain cautious application of measures
to curb the spread of virus will be with
us for some time to come as with the
need to coordination of covet related
measures we intend to continue to ensure
a coordinated approach
vexing sharing with countries most in
need is an important gesture of
solidarity as presidency we will
therefore also do our best to contribute
to an accelerated efforts as regard eu
vaccine donation to third countries
dear members of the european parliament
prime minister yansha addressed you in
this hemi cycle in july and stated that
i quote the most important thing for our
short-term future is to stop the
pandemic and recover economically as
soon as possible the virus has put a
halt on social life and the economy for
the greater part of 2020 and 2021 it is
estimated that covet 19 took away more
than 5 million jobs in first half of
2020. the economy the eu economy has
shrunk by six percent yet in the second
quarter of 2021 we see a remarkable
recovery across the eu
this recovery must include the green and
digital transition allow me to stress
the proposal on digital services and
digital markets
the council is working on both acts
intensively and we aim to agree
council's position by the end of the
year
as mrs wonderlion stated today digital
is a make or break issue the presidency
can only applaud to the announcement of
building a new eu cheap ecosystem and
new cyber security act
i would like to thank the commission for
the tremendous work on the fee for 55
package in very short time you presented
a huge legislative agenda across eu
policies and with far-reaching impact on
our economy industry and our way of life
all of this is also very important in
light of our preparation for the cop 26
in glasgow
it is never easy to change our social
and economic patterns even more so if
this implies higher cost for our
citizens therefore the social
consequences of this transition have to
be properly addressed so we complement
the announcement of new climate social
fund
we will walk together with the
commission to ensure that the council
swiftly endorse the necessary act for
the adoption of the national recovery
plans of the remaining member states and
the disbursement of funds these are
essential for recovery since the
beginning of the slovenian presidency we
have been able to approve 18 national
plans i'm convinced that this will
provide additional boost for the
european recovery ladies and gentlemen
all of these topics plus rule of law
strategic autonomy global action
migration and asylum pack european
defense union all these will determine
our future and the future of next
generation for decades to ahead of us
this is why they are part of the
conference on the future of europe
discussion managed jointly by the
european parliament european commission
and
council
we should be able to ensure that we
engage with the and listen to our
citizens in search to answer the
question in what kind of europe they
wish to live this discussion should go
far beyond the brussels bubble
and far beyond our capitals i'm glad
that first citizens panel is about to
kick off at the end of this week it is
also important that when debating the
future of you we also look beyond
current borders process of enlargement
is taking place the region of western
balkans has eu perspective as presidency
slovenia pays special attention to the
western balkans the eu western balkans
summit will take place in slovenia in
october enlargement should be one of the
eu strategic priorities accession of the
western broken country should be part of
our common vision
finally we welcome the commission's
letter of intent which the council will
discuss next week together with the
annual foresight report we are convinced
that the report will be a useful tool
not only for political deliberation but
also for finding proper expert solution
to the issues
that the world of today and tomorrow
face
we look forward to continuing the
fruitful dialogue among the three
institutions on our common priorities
for the next year
the council will subsequently in
november discuss the new commissioned
work program with the view to the joint
declaration on legislative priorities
for 22.
our joint program can help us and our
three institutions
achieve result in a focused and targeted
way let me reaffirm the council's
commitment to this process and assure
you that the presidency will continue to
be a determined partner
let me once again reassure
that presidency possess a strong soul
european soul
and if you ask me
how to summarize today's state of the
union speech
in only three words
i would say
together
resilent
europe
the exact motto of slovenian eu
presidency
thank you very much mr logar
i now give the floor to daniel caspari
for two minutes
colleagues
commission president has very clearly
set out the situation we have kept our
promises in the summer all uh europeans
received the offer of a vaccine
the uh short time working uh support has
guaranteed uh jobs for uh thousands of
families
we have created the corona recovery fund
it's an unprecedented step
750 billion euros to support
people and businesses combat the
consequences of the pandemic you said
madam president this year
by next year at the latest all states of
the eu will be at least as strong
economically as they were before the
pandemic and that is of course partly
due to the fact that all the member
states know
that the corona recovery plan represents
a unique opportunity and that each
member state will have to
avail themselves of but we see that the
left
part of this house want to keep all of
these temporary instruments forever
um
the the left want to introduce new
transfers from reach to poor countries
in the banking union uh where
our german
savers and investors will have to uh
foot the bill for irresponsible
behaviour in other countries you are in
favor of a
um
loans being taken out by the eu
you want to turn the european stability
union into a debt union you want to take
money away from some and redistribute to
others and tell people what they need
for them what we want is something
different we want a europe of solidarity
of freedom and of
assuming one's own responsibilities
europe that uh protects people and
offers them opportunities we want a
union that is always always show
solidarity in need but rewards uh
performance and ask people to take
responsibility for their actions and
that is the difference between our
stability union and your debt union this
is a debate that we will be continuing
over the next weeks and months in this
house but it's also an important issue
in the upcoming election campaign in
germany and it's a point that we need to
make clear to our citizens
[Applause]
thank you
good morning everyone
i will now give the floor to simona
bonaflee the four for one and a half
minutes
thank you president
we are leaving behind us a period of
months that have been difficult but
which have taught us a tough lesson the
pandemic on one side and the afghan
crisis on the other have once again
shown us that the charges of our age can
only be confronted if europe is united
solid and shows solidarity
while being aware of its role in the
world
a return
to
national sovereignty is
is
simply an idea that is no longer legal
tender
we're coming up to the halfway mark of
this parliamentary term the next two and
a half years will be crucial to provide
some fresh impetus for europe
we have deployed
an amazing instrument next generation
eu to get the economy going again
but that's just the starting point
we have to leave austerity behind us
and we need to
reform our economic governance system
which needs
an ongoing eurozone fiscal capacity and
within the european semester we need to
include the un
sustainable development goals the green
deal and the social
pillar
europe
if it's going to show more solidarity
cannot
turn aside
from the the pain of the afghan peoples
as we have been doing
with just having humanitarian corridors
we would we're seeing
selfish movements
which would show that we can only
move ahead if we finally have a true
european foreign and defense policy
present
from the land
as as we were saying if something seems
impossible
you can do it so we're looking to you to
show leadership to to europe
thank you monica's money is the next
speaker for two minutes
dear madam president dear colleagues
as we start a new political year
we look back on the turbulent summer
we are still coping with the corona
epidemic
the american retreat from afghanistan
brought the taliban back to powers
and fierce
back in the eyes of women and girls
we also saw flooding due to heavy
rainfall and extreme heat on our own
continent
this summer has reminded us there is
still much to be done
on geopolitics
climate
health
digital security our role in the world
and migration to name a few
there is a need
for a strong
european cooperation
i think the coming political year should
revolve around one word
deliver
deliver on our role in a world that is
increasingly unstable
deliver on climate policies to cut down
emissions
meet our climate target in 2050 and
adapt to new climate situations
deliver on digital
deliver on security for our citizens and
standing for our common values and the
protection of the rule of law and
democracy
using all instruments available
deliver on migration to prevent people
from taking dangerous routes that take
them a long way from home and possibly a
life in uncertainty
deliver or revitalize the european union
with the conference of the future of
europe with our citizens at its core
dear madam president
your commission is almost halfway
and the next half must be about
delivering
there is enough opportunity to do so and
today we call on you to do so
not only words but action and
implementation and your introduction you
mentioned also that you already have
delivered but for your new europe it's
not enough
but let me also turn me to my colleagues
we as european parliament also have to
deliver to meet the expectations of our
citizens
last week we as renewed published our
roadmap in paris
for the coming months and extended our
hand to all those in european parliament
that wants to deliver
let me ask you all
are you ready to take that
responsibility with us like a
parliamentary majority and deliver on
all of those important issues
we as renew are ready and it's time to
deliver to deliver
deliver thank you
[Applause]
thank you i would ask everyone to
respect their speaking time please
now jordy soleil has the floor for one
and a half minutes
thank you chairman madam president the
pandemic has shown that when european
institutions take the lead in facing
common challenges the eu
can deliver results vaccine development
and purchase the compete certificate
next generation you despite some initial
flows what has been achieved so far is
truly remarkable
with a terrible contradiction though
that we now have millions of doses
waiting in our in the freezers while in
many other countries vaccination has
hardly begun so we need to step up our
solidarity
if we were to face all the big
challenges with the same leadership and
determination then as a union we would
achieve much more
and we know we don't lack challenges for
instance many of our european companies
are in a race against time
to maintain their competitiveness
despite growing demand they face rising
energy and raw material prices shortage
of components and fair competition from
third countries and we cannot achieve
the goals of the green deal without them
let's support our industry with an
ambitious strategy let's translate the
strategic autonomy into something more
than just fancy words
on another note madam ponder lion today
the catalan and spanish governments are
formally resuming negotiations on how to
solve the ongoing political conflict
between catalonia and spain
i know you will argue this is an
internal matter but we will know this is
not entirely true
the you should follow this negotiation
and embrace it as much as much as it can
because in a democratic space as we want
the european union to be
conflicts on self-determination require
a democratic and negotiated solution
other
authoritarian-like responses have no
place in our union thank you
with thank you the next speaker is
nicola bay
for two minutes
miss wonderland
you
graced us with an endless speech as ever
on the state of human union we can see
you're very pleased with yourself but
you're the only one who is
as far as migration is concerned 2015
had already showed the failure of the
european institutions today the
situation is ever more disastrous and
pressure on external borders is growing
lithuania and poland are facing hybrid
aggression manipulated by foreign powers
they're responding with tough matters
are you finally going to give them clear
support
rather than
defending your migration and asylum in
fact which adds a lack of approach to
your impotence
well when it comes to to to turkey
europe is is prepared to
give erdogan
the upper hand
what those
who
think that the european
export
um european political model can be
exported around would have seen that
that's a failure
we we need to organize
the hosting of afghan regions
in the surrounding region in no
circumstances must we allow them to come
to europe
we have to
put pakistan in the in the dock pakistan
enjoys
economic
advantages from europe and it it owes us
something
you said that it's our responsibility to
host african
refugees no your responsibility is to
keep europe and its citizens safe and
stable
and i'm amazed to hear something that
the taliban are being inclusive and we
might actually give afghanistan some
money so
so these in brussels are prepared to
talk to her
to the the taliban but they're trying to
stigmatize hungary
we can see the rule of law being used as
a fig leaf
to impose
social um
ideas having an impact on people's
health and and family life
the measures taken against berlin and
hungary with
with this conditionality course is
showing that post curvice 19
aid is is being used to apply political
pressure
you're already
carrying out a political trial in
hungary basically the european union is
in a a very polished state
thank you
the next speaker is biata shitwa she has
two minutes
thank you very much
president
ladies and gentlemen we're looking at
what the state of the european union is
well we can say that the facade of the
european construct is nice it's been
nicely painted colorful
but within the walls there's chaos that
reigns
and the european institutions are taking
decisions again and again that don't
fall within their
treaty
rights we have to go back to the
foundation of our common european house
the christian values tolerance equality
all that goes with that
the president
quoted robert schumann on several
occasions and i would say as well
that the founding fathers
deemed this foundation to be important
too hence my question
on which treaty basis but also moral
basis does the commission
believe
it can punish
voivod shafts and
regions and municipalities who are
defending
christian values which articles in the
treaties allow
the rule of law to be linked with
payments from
the common purse where does it say that
arbitrary decisions by an individual
official from the european union can
decide
as to whether the legal system of a
given member state
is in keeping with european law or not
when that is the right and sole right of
the sovereign member states because
europe is here for the europeans it's
our european house it should serve the
europeans not the european institutions
which
are trying to grab more and more of this
european house thank you
thank you the next speaker
is our colleague sierra rego for one
minute
gracias presidente
thank you
mr president
miss van der lion
uh i understand that you want to tell us
that everything is just fine and dandy
but of course
it depends
on
what your uh bank accounts tell you to
see whether it's fine or dandy or not i
mean maybe the pharmaceutical companies
are happy with their profits
we are following an extreme right
migration strategy which is
giving riches to
to the few
and serving
not serving our population um we're not
meeting the paris accords objectives
most people in europe are not seeing uh
positive results people have lost their
jobs people who can't pay their
electricity bills uh
open arms the ngos who are fighting to
save the lives of migrants trying to
cross the mediterranean and those who
are trying to stop climate change
let us not uh
congratulate ourselves on what has been
achieved let's remember that the
breeding ground for the extreme right is
this inequality this poverty and this
fear which uh uh has
been provoked by the right-wing policies
we've been pursuing in europe
thank you the next speaker is tomas
on
brussels
as having debates with the countries of
central eastern europe and then brussels
tries to decide this using
force that's not acceptable of course
we're talking about mainstream
ideologies
and
they look at us in a patronizing fashion
with their colonializing ideas they
attack us about 60 million
eastern europeans are being attacked but
we don't complain
what brussels is doing is you are
abusing your power you're trying to
force something on us
your ideas
about lgbti rights
your ideas about
the constitutional law and lgtbi
values and that really is undermining
europe we
love freedom we love our homeland
and for us
cooperation in europe is much more
important than it being undermined thank
you
thank you
the next speaker is andre khalidskiy
our
future
the future of the the europe we want to
build as a strong active europe of
solidarity that's what our citizens are
looking to us to achieve
and europe has to be there for the
citizens
polls as european citizens
also have expectations of of action
being taken on the climate
this has a particular impact for the
younger generations
and we're
looking for cooperation and health
there's more to this than just the
pandemic and its consequences
we've set up a special committee on
cancer in the open parliament these are
things
which are truly of interest to our
citizens
and then again there's the question of
the rule of law european funds
have to
be be
used according to purposes which they
intended that's to be proper monitoring
to make sure they get to
the the right um
end users no
national government
should be interfering with the process
eighty eighty percent
of polls
according to wells see
their future clearly as part of europe
because in europe they see
safety security and the prospect of
development 88
that was the finding
in the polish parliament
there's only one party
where there's a slight majority which it
doesn't have in the senate
police society
wants tolerance and democratic values
and we want to take our place in europe
that's the statement i wanted to make
here
for the government too i wanted to say
this to
the european institutions
we want to europe with more solidarity
thank you
i'll give the four now to pedro marcus
for a minute and a half
dear colleagues dear
president madam president of the
commission the puerto social summit was
not a beauty contest
that means that from now on we must take
every chance to implement the social
pillar objectives in europe we need a
reduction of poverty to be at the
forefront of european policies
unfortunately i have to say i didn't see
it high up in your priorities today
that is why this group is clearly
calling for an anti-poverty law in
europe with clear binding targets to
improve the lives of millions of people
is the commission ready to respond to
such a strong commitment madam president
moreover we need all resources we can
get to fight poverty and inequalities we
need economic reforms and rules that
push for green and social investments to
pursue sustainable well-being for all
that is also why we pushed for the
recovery plans to focus on the social
conditions the commission must ensure
that this is a true priority because we
were not in porto for the photos or the
beautiful weather we were there to make
a difference for the future
if you were also there
for the same reasons as we did this is
the time to set your priorities
correctly madam president we want the
the end of extreme poverty to become one
of your biggest endeavors we cannot be
clear on this matter from the side of
our uh political family thank you so
much
[Applause]
thank you the next speaker is stefan
sejourney
he has two minutes
thank you mr president madam president
colleagues
we're forced to know that the word
crisis is part of our everyday language
we all use the words climate crisis
health crisis diplomatic crisis so we
have a two-fold responsibility we have
to show our citizens that
europe can rise to the challenge of
these crises and we have to go further
to defend the european model
we did step up to the plate we did
launch the recovery plan and we've
achieved our european vaccination
targets and the green deal that we're
working on will make it a pos will make
it possible for us to achieve carbon
neutrality in 2050 and
we also
have stepped up to the plate but we need
to go further now and we need to be more
effective in defending europe
madam president defending europe means
being intransigent to defend the rule of
law
defending europe means having the means
to finance ourselves on the basis of own
resources
and
i heard what you said madam and we
certainly won't accept any steps back uh
from these commitments uh by the
commission we also uh
want to
break the taboo of european defense in
an unstable world we want to have the
means
to carry out a just green transition and
we want to defend a european digital
model which is uh democratic which
protects our data and which creates new
opportunities for our businesses so to
sum up defending europe means defending
a sovereign europe
madam president we expect of you and of
your commission
ambition
and effectiveness
and our political group will stand by
you
but i would turn to some of my
colleagues in this parliament as other
renew members have and call on all of
those who are saying that we need to go
further and faster that we should uh
follow through on this
uh the nationalists by the way who are
conspicuous by their absence in in the
debate
will take every opportunity to get
organized together so we too we
pro-europeans should also be more
effective in our work we need to go on
the offensive
the commission's job is to make
proposals but we as parliamentarians
need to mobilize and form a coalition
for the second half of our mandate we
have two and a half years left and we
have a huge responsibility
[Applause]
thank you
the next speaker is anna cavazcini for
two minutes
dear commission president ladies and
gentlemen
today we're discussing the state of the
union and to be frank
the state of our union when it comes to
the climate concerns me the fact that in
greece there are towns and villages
which are being burnt down have to be
evacuated or that in germany that the
masses have to flee from floods it shows
us that we're facing a climate crisis
now
president you have promised to make
europe climate neutral as quickly as
possible
and also
you compared this with the
humans landing on the moon well this is
all well and good but if you've got the
handbrake on you're not going to make it
to the moon
the leading
climate scientists are warning that the
1.5 degree
limit will be reached before
expected
and so we cannot wait until measures are
introduced by you come into effect after
2030
because we will be robbing the future of
their freedom climate protection also
requires us to assume global
responsibility even though the amazon is
just about to collapse the commission
nevertheless is still
keeping to a trade agreement with the
amazon and helps to continue
deforestation there a green deal is not
just
pulling on the handbrake i want to be
clear here
these false words and
double standards are not acceptable we
can do more
we have the nobel peace prize we've
generated a single market let's review
the single market to make sure that it
works well let's leave fossil fuels
behind quickly and have a circular
economy that's genuine
and what goes hand in hand with our
internal market is our supplies we have
to make sure that supplies are not based
on climate destruction and human rights
violations that's why i'm very pleased
that today you took on by that green
demand
to make sure
that we are not importing anything that
is a product of
forced labor we need to bring an
effective end to slavery around the
world thank you
thank you the next speaker
is yak madison
for one and a half minutes
thank you mr president
thank you
madame van der laan
the green deal
and the
commission
fit for 55 package um
uh what you are offering to save the
world i understand that
the commission may well genuinely
believe that uh
500 million
inhabitants of europe can alone turn
back the tide
but
china and india and other states
don't share in your
green deal and you're fit for 55 ideas
yet the europeans are paying for all of
this i think it will all lead to nothing
and it won't save the climate
as others have mentioned
recently
in estonia we have reached new highs in
electricity prices
if we
keep on taxing
kerosene and other fuels
it might be all right for members of
this parliament or members of this
commission they'll be able to still
afford airfares but uh ordinary citizens
will only be able to fly somewhere every
three years also because of the hike in
prices this will
entail and it will also have an impact
on our competitiveness
ms van der lion
raised the idea of a european army
i don't want to
repeat uh mistakes of the past i don't
think the european commission should be
deciding on
the army there should be something for
the member states and the commission
should keep his hands off
regard
thank you the next weekend
for one minute
electricity prices are shooting up
costs are going up for firms
now you've announced a new
reduction target of
55 percent
your your proposals are not going to
protect europe's
borders and then the mafia organizations
are still going to be dumping people on
this
you're not shouldering responsibility in
the the kobe crisis you and china
have been encouraging these
investment
arrangements which are destroying
european industry
all you're trying to do is get more
power in in brussels
in this conference and you preach to
member states
you're investigating the hungarian and
polish
people forgetting the commission is at
the service of the the member states not
the other way around there you are
talking to the afghan taliban having
painted a sorry picture
in the eyes of global public opinion
you're taking this deer as used to
approach we're still preaching in the
the desert
despite
your
your your jokes and um your reproaches
will be out there on the street
thank you
i'll give the floor now to nikolai
williamson for one minute
dear president
usually from the line
you talk about the need for a socially
just
transition
but what is the reality
tens of thousands of construction
workers risk
losing their lives in the green
transition if protections against the
deadly asbestos
do not go hand in hand with the
renovation wave of millions of buildings
in europe
i thought the commission was committed
to a vision zero of work-related deaths
but yesterday i
as a reporter on the asbestos file
received this letter from the commission
warning against the lowering of the
limit value even though we all know
this will save lives
dear president we do not need sweet
words on a socially just transition
we need action
[Applause]
[Music]
instead of the state of the inextricably
anti-popular eu i'd rather present you
the real state of the peoples
who are without defense in the face of
the pandemic
who feel the brunt of the shrinking
public health systems the dramatic
shortages of staff
precious infrastructure is sold out to
the private sector for profiteering and
then we have the recovery fund the
quote-unquote green deals all this is
paid by the peoples at the end of the
day with
working conditions from the middle ages
telework redundancies and certain
pensions with
quote unquote green and digital taxes
with skyrocketing cost of living and at
the end of the day governments like the
greek uh government pay at the end of
the day
with the people's money and then they
use this money to brandish the flag of
war all over the planet with or without
the us and nato
leading people to flee their countries
so growth for the
many is a myth it's growth for the few
suffering for the people only organized
struggle can bring about modern people's
rights
to upset the prevalence of capital and
disengagement from the eu
thank you next speaker secretary
two minutes
thank you mr president president fonder
line welcome back to the european
parliament dear colleagues over the
course of the last year we have made
together far-reaching decisions we have
together overcome the most difficult
part of the pandemic we have together
made decisions to help
those people affected by the pandemic
and to make sure that the european union
will be stronger in the future exactly
one year ago we had the will to act
together but we did not have the tools
we did not have a vaccine we did not
have an eu vaccination plan in place we
did not have a budget for the european
union for the next years and we did not
have a recovery plan in place due to our
common action over the course of the
last year all of these elements are in
place and now we have these tools in
place now we have to make sure that
particularly in helping
the people and the economy recover money
from the european level is well spent
and i have madame president two calls to
make firstly
we have to think when and how we pay
back um the amounts from a next
generation eu and we have to make sure
that we pay these back without affecting
the budget of the european union in the
future without needing to tell farmers
students or researchers that have less
money for them and the common answer
which we have agreed council commission
and parliament is to go for own
resources of the european union to
provide stability for the financing of
the european union in the future and
this is why madam president i kindly
asked the commission to make a proposal
as we have discussed on the digital levy
on the carbon border adjustment tax and
on the revision of the european trading
the emission trading system soon over
the course of the next weeks and
secondly dear colleagues
we also have to progress with greening
and digital we cannot afford to put the
transition on towards the green economy
on small and medium-sized enterprises
and also on people affected by higher
bills for electricity
specifically the most vulnerable
citizens particularly in this global
context of increased energy prices i
call upon the commission i ask us all
together to make sure that we use all
the instruments which we have at our
disposal and create new instruments if
needed to help the vulnerable citizens
on this transition to the green economy
as during the pandemic we have to be on
the side of the people thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you very much
next speaker
madame
ellen fritz on one and a half minutes
president thank you very much
thank you er president of the commission
vanderlaan for
your speech and important
promises
equality
a green and sustainable europe
for the future that's how we the social
democrats describe the world that we
would like to
live in it's high time for the eu to
step up the pace the un plain climate
panel
shows uh that the climate situation is
worse than we thought the eu's equality
institute institute has taken uh
60 years to
achieve equality my grandchildren
shouldn't have to
wait until they're 65 before europe
becomes equal it's urgent we need a
quicker climate adaptation with more
green jobs for all
for all
one in every three women
in europe today does not have a job we
need to strengthen equality
between the genders a directive on
violence against women needs to
prevent women from suffering of violence
each member state needs to stand up for
our common
values otherwise they shouldn't get any
money so
freedom security equality i want to see
a green and sustainable europe where
people
can believe in the future and we need to
act now thank you
thank you the next speaker
mr luis scaricano two minutes
senora president
dear colleagues dear commissioners the
state of our union today is robust
we're
in the midst of a pandemic which cost us
so many lives but these citizens that
did their bit to save lives
we made sure that our societies didn't
stop the people got vaccinated
and we did meet the challenge in the eu
europe is it europe europe is useful to
its citizens it's come up with a
response to the worst health crisis in a
century
now
we're talk we have three quarters of our
population vaccinated that's more than
in the uk and the u.s we're seeing
economic recovery
all
european countries have fought
with the same tools the short time
working guaranteed loans and direct aid
to smes together we launched a
an ambitious recovery plan which will
put our economies on a greener
more sustainable and more human path
in spain today there are many people who
are alive thanks to the vaccines bought
by the european union in spain there are
many people who have kept their jobs
thanks to the short time working on
furlough schemes financed by the eu
in spain many people will find work
thanks to the recovery plan
we have
managed to get off the ground we are
very lucky to be europeans
and it's been shown that our model of
open and tolerant democracy protects us
better
from any crisis than nationalism
populism and so on
and we need to take firm steps against
the pandemic still we need to vaccinate
the world let's do that
and let's make sure that
europeans can feel even more proud to be
europeans thank you very much
thank you next speaker
ernest o'tesson
one minute
madam president
i think in your speech
it lacked ambition in three areas which
i for the second part of your mandate
ambition in fighting climate change the
un report has shown us that we're in the
worst scenario not doing enough and yet
in brussels
we are actually postponing
uh doing everything until 2030 we need
to do more and more quickly secondly
afghanistan shows we need to make more
rapid progress towards a geopolitical
union and i have to say
that the proposal of eliminating vat for
the european defense industry is not the
solution we need to think about ensuring
that our decision-making processes are
more agile with more involvement of the
member states the commission needs to
lead that and then the third area is a
new framework for economic governance
you didn't say much about that subject
today i do understand your prudence but
if we want actually to have
a fair resolution of the economic crisis
we can't use the paradigm we had before
and deep reform will be necessary over
coming months thank you
thank you
next speaker
harold velinski one minute
thank you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
for the 11th time we have the state of
the union report
and
it's
not just the title that's been copied
from the u.s
we see that there is a development
towards centralism like the
model of the us that is the attempt that
is being made this is wrong
um
europe is a euro provide
of diversity
and we hear the same things over and
over again about the climate the
european um maca industry is being
destroyed
and then migration
and we've seen mistakes since 2015 more
and more people are coming in
as asylum seekers but three quarters of
them don't actually need
protection
so
state of the union it's a real um
breakdown climate hysteria
a migration policy which takes europe's
identity away
change your
policy then we will do better with the
state of the union thank you
thank you very much
next speaker
is
mr
krasnostepski
one half minutes
there is one problem that was omitted
this is something that is of
a grave concern to us and may determine
the future of europe
there is a lot of doubts whether the
commission is acting legally based on
the treaties article 13 says that every
institution must work within the
framework
provided for in the treaty however we
are witnessing the process where
by commission and parliament are
broadening their competences at the
expense of member states meddling with
their legal systems as far as it was
only poland and hungary
we could have ignored it we could say
that these countries are not adhering
to the principles of the rule of law
however the same voices are coming from
other member states michelle barnier
for example talked about the legal
supremacy that must be 101 over by
friends
this is
not only an electoral trick because
andreas foscor from the constitutional
tribunal said that the
commission
and the court are trying to
build the federal state
it was confirmed and corroborated by
others also by
german lawyers in the communication
published in the german press so there
is no doubt that we are dealing with a
great issue a commission is forgetting
that it is not a super government which
is above national governments we should
deal with this issue and we will be
discussing this
during the conference on the future of
europe this is a a great problem this
refers to the very architecture of the
european union thank you very much thank
you mr chairman thank you madam
president
thank you very much next speaker
madame bjork one minute
old founder
as
usual
you paint uh a very
nice picture of what europe is doing but
that's not
the case we have a climate crisis the
scientists and young people if you
listen to them are saying that not
enough is being done we need to do more
and we need to do it quicker
the
left is also standing up for protection
being giving
to those who flee
we do not accept the migration policy
currently
at play
and to those listening to us i want to
say that the
the left is the only group standing up
against militarization
and now we're talking about an eu army
put the money into equality that would
be a better solution and i also see that
democracy and rule of law come right at
the end of your speech but those are the
building stones for our
future it's time to get down to work uh
companies should not be determining our
future
thank you very much next speaker
martin
one minute
madam president colleagues
firstly i would like to complement the
commission for the extraordinary
achievement of tackling the enormous
challenges of the pandemic
regarding our economies the recovery
facility proved to be a strong tool to
ease the strain of member states
as the latest surveys show a big
majority of our citizens have faith in
the facility
but 85 percent also expect transparency
and effective control to you on the use
of such funds
now in hungary today we have an
authoritarian government that
effectively uses european funds to
deconstruct rule of law the finance
minister of which already openly
speculates on leaving the eu if finances
are withheld while the two-thirds
majority of hungarian citizens are
pro-european
these are the desperate cries of the
crumbling regime
madame van der lion i listened carefully
to your nice words on european values
but also heard the gobbledygook on
safeguarding them
you have a clear mandate
you have an instrument the rule of law
mechanism which is effective as of 1st
of january please use it thank you
thank you very much next speaker to lose
monserrat
two minutes
president madam president the day of
democracy is the best day to hold this
debate we've seen various crises
affecting the eu over decades we've
and we have lost
our loved ones people have lost jobs
recently we've seen brexit nationalism
these are examples of false president
promises which make the present worse
we need to move towards the better
future we need to avoid opportunism and
separatism that weakens us the
afghanistan
crisis
is a humanitarian crisis
it is a step back and there should be a
turning point for europe we need to
focus on defending
freedom in countries such as cuba
venezuela and
nicaragua we need to have a better
response in external policy and we need
to make better progress in the field of
defense otherwise
europe will be vulnerable and dependent
on other global actors
and
we've seen exemplary leadership
with vaccination
we have acted in a spirit of brotherhood
we need to be vigilant in terms of
ensuring efficient
and transparent distribution we need a
europe creating opportunities and high
quality jobs that
it'll be a challenge to reach an
agreement on migration and
to protect the rule of law and due the
event independence of the judiciary and
we
represent
these values but we need to have means
to
defend these values
otherwise that we will be betraying our
great legacy we don't want the eu to end
up as an empty shell which cannot offer
a better future to our children the eu
continues to be must continue to be in
the vanguard in the forefront in the
world thank you
thank you very much
next speaker
billionaire
one and a half minutes
thank you mr president
every crisis presents an opportunity as
well but only if we have the courage to
do great things our recovery plans
obligate member states to invest into
digital infrastructure and
sustainability we must use this
opportunity to develop new economic
models which will in turn create new
better and more sustainable jobs however
we must not disregard the social
dimension of the recovery because in
most eu member states the prices are
rising while the salaries remain the
same we must not forget that some have
largely profited in this crisis
large multinational companies notorious
for not respecting the rights of their
workers and our right to privacy have
gained big money
however they're still skillfully
avoiding paying tax
it is unacceptable the digital giants
are paying a tax percentage which is
multiple times lower than that of for
instance smes we must strike a global
deal in order to do away with tax havens
we cannot allow that big players are not
made to pay over
825 billion euros per year while our
citizens regularly receive warning
letters
citizens should not be the ones to pay
for the consequences of the crisis
to conclude
this crisis has shown that there is no
going back there is no going back to
austerity measures
the shared mechanism has proven to be
very successful in fighting unemployment
eu rules should be revised in order to
reduce disparities between the rich and
the poor thank you
thank you very much next speaker michal
two minutes
thank you very much mr chair madam
president
i want to say that you're indeed right
that the eu has uh weathered the past
year many uh better than many had
expected we caught up on vaccination
rates with the leading countries around
the world and our economic recovery is
underway of course we still have ways to
go to defeat covet both in europe uh and
abroad but the eu has indeed proved many
of its doubters wrong
looking ahead though what myself and
many of my colleagues are especially
concerned is the continuing democratic
backsliding in several member states
president wanda lyon spoke about various
ambitions that the eu should pursue from
health care to military capacity from
climate change to social policy and of
course i support all these ambitions but
the success of any of these future
projects relies on a shared bed of
principles and values none of these
programs will that the president outline
will will be successful will will work
well in the long run if the european
union turns into a disjointed club of
democracies and other regime types
because the trust we need the mutual
trust we need to sustain these
initiatives and of course this
sense of purpose to drive them will
evaporate if this is not the case
because what we're seeing today the
suppression of critical voices
state-sponsored hate campaigns attacks
on independent institutions all of this
suggests that some of our members of our
community are increasingly drifting away
and the eu of course must recognize that
the orchestrators of these liberal
developments are first and foremost
governments elite while citizen support
for the eu remains very high in both
hungary and poland this is why the
european commission needs to take action
as we have called for it needs to put a
fight for its values because if we don't
we would never have the political
strength and the cohesion to move
forward with these ambitious projects
therefore president from the lion rule
of law and democracy is not just another
agenda among many
it's not just another box to take not
just another paragraph in a speech it's
a precondition for anything else we want
to do together thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you next speaker
one minute
you president madame vanderlian
jean minay wrote
that humans only accept change when
they're required to and that's only when
there's a crisis
we have
such conditions now so it's a time for
change madame de lime but also for
audacity and courage
let's take and take a look at the
european project
it was very daring but it required
people to listen to dare to change and i
think that's what we need now and for
you to surprise us and yourselves
you're not on your own the european
parliament will support you
but we'll also criticize
conference on the future of europe is a
contribution which moves more towards
more europe
and i am
open to developing an inclusive green
european identity along with our young
people and to launch future cultural
diplomacy which will rival that of china
and the us
please madame vanderlian br jean monet
of the 21st century thank you
thank you next speaker
head of annamans
one minute
madam
president
you've set out at length
that the eu wants to extend its powers
take more powers from the member states
it's no longer cooperation it means one
single state
now
we're talking about 116
parties
from all our nations we're representing
the freedoms of the european people
we're in favor of european cooperation
but it has to be co-operation
we shouldn't get the feeling that
people's rights are being slowly taken
away their rights to decide on their own
future the european union
is at the playground of radical
forces
wanting a europe without
nations we believe in a europe of
nations on the basis of respect for
history and specificities and the values
uniting our
nations but we don't want to
thank you next speaker
hurt bourgeois
one minute
madam
president
you quite rightly said
that
we need a structural
reforms
5g
but the whole a single market needs to
be completed
particularly with a view to our smes we
need subsidiarity
and diversity to be put at the core of
your policy and i've heard nothing about
that citizens want to their jobs to be
protected it's good that you're talking
about cyber security but we also need a
proper functioning migration pact and
instruments against
dumping
we need uh the eu to be a global
actor we need to be the engine of
multilateralism we need more uh
free trade agreements and uh we need to
be players for freedom and stability
thank you next speaker
joel pimento
one minute
madam
president we've had a testing year
when faced with the
pandemic we've seen the defense of
pharmaceutical companies even when it
came to trying to lift patents now
european funds are used but conditions
are set
by the eu rather than depending on the
challenges and problems that the member
states have
even countries with deficits like
portuguese that then we have the
stability pact
what we should be doing is ensuring that
we have better public services
particularly in health we would like to
dedicate from this fact now
convergence convergence on backsliding
is something we don't want
the green transition does
require de-industrialization but also
more jobs we need a cap which includes
fair
involvement of all whilst increasing
production
but our policies unfortunately don't
seem to be serving the people
particularly the people of portugal
thank you
thank you very much
next speaker is claro poncetti objects
one minute
president london ryan thank you for
speaking so quietly of the union's
challenges with the law of law too bad
that you were not
very precise but i presume you were
referring to spain
yes mr sanchez is not talking of
dialogue yes nine political prisoners
are finally home after years in jail but
the prosecution of catalan dissidents
including state espionage of political
opponents goes on and relenting
yesterday it was announced and 13
activists will have to stand drive on
accused terrorism charges that are
totally fabricated so what is mr sanchez
proposal political and cultural
repression economic suffocation
submission
but the catalan people will not give in
to fear on saturday hundreds of
thousands march on the streets of
barcelona their message was loud and
clear we catalans have the right to
self-determination and we voted to be
independent on october 1st 2017.
no other political movement in europe
mobilizes popular support and has the
resilience of the catalan cause in spite
of spanish repression in spite of the
institutions of europe indifference we
shall overcome
thank you very much
thank you very much next speaker
francois savier bellamy two minutes
madam president
you gave a lucid diagnosis and a rap map
road map
you spoke about the independence of
our countries vis-a-vis asia you talked
about protecting health we need
to protect ourselves against future
crises which will come when we least
expect now the multiplication of
climate standards will mean that we'll
get more imports from china the
taxonomy will mean will depend on
russian gas
and a commission's study shows that
its owner cap will reduce production
which will be
a disaster for
our farmers for our agriculture now you
want to stop
products of forced labor being marketed
in europe why are you signing an
economic agreement with china which
still hasn't ratified its ban
you seem to show powerlessness vis-a-vis
migratory flowers
flows what about the
uh
what about the front text messaging you
you're talking about your
support
when it comes to migration but millions
are going to uh erdogan and
commissioner
johansson said that the
commission did not finance walls or
barriers
now
we listened with interest to what you
were saying about ex that exemption for
the defense industry but there are major
difficulties for funding that sector and
the european directive on working time
creates
major legal insecurity for all european
armed forces and a word for youth now
they have been
sorely tried
and it's a bit of a shame
to call 2022 the year of youth after the
750 billion of debt handed down to our
young people the year before
we
need to have the means for europe to
master its destiny
next is marek belka for one and a half
minutes
malam chair
well i'm president
the last two years were a testing time
for the european union
but here we are
we are still standing
however the next year must bring us
decisions on various
important topics
first
how to reform stability and growth pact
in the short term we still need to
address the health social and economic
consequences of covid
yes we must return to stability criteria
but this requires a transition
a premature withdrawal of stimulating
measures will only harm our economies
in the long term the fiscal rules need
to change so that they will not kill
investment and growth
we have a pandemic behind us and digital
and climate transition ahead
an ambitious focus on a digital and
green revolution needs flexibility in
the rules and this is what we will
insist on
from the trade perspective we expect the
commission to be engaged in the process
of reactivating the negotiating function
of the wto
ensuring the proper functioning of the
dispute settlement mechanism and making
sure that we can better address future
value chain distortions
finally
we insist on the introduction and
implementation of the mandatory due
diligence rules aimed at all companies
in the eu market
which actions cause harm to the
environment workers and human rights
the upcoming year should bring us change
we hope that with this commission it
will also have a social dimension at
heart
thank you
thank you very much and mr belkan next
is
for two minutes vice president the floor
is yours
thank you madam president dear
colleagues this has been an incredibly
tough year
but we are now seeing delight at the end
of the tunnel and looking to our
economic recovery
we need to get back on our two feet and
regain
competitiveness as soon as possible
we now have the money
but the policies we adopt and the kind
of business environment we create will
determine how we emerge from the crisis
and how quickly
the approach we take on digital and
climate transitions are key
while we shape this new digital decade
we must be careful to avoid
over-regulating
which will just hold our companies
especially smes back
we need them to be free to innovate and
thus grow
we must find the isolationism
protectionism tendencies in the name of
european sovereignty
we can be strong
and
open to the world
we can have strategic crisis reserves
but still be open to free trade and open
industry
without a global alliance we will just
fall more behind other world powers
now is not the time to hide but to get
into the game
we all want to protect the environment
but we have to take into account the
impact on the lives of our citizens
it was a mistake to include private
houses and the ets and we need to fix it
the policies we adopt in brussels must
be about making lives better
both for our citizens and our
businesses
we must make policy with
and for our citizens
not against them thank you very much
thank you very much mr lance of our next
bus icouch for one minute
thank you very much and thank you madam
president for your state of the union
which had quite some a lot of good
proposals but of course in one minute i
will have to focus on the criticism uh
you you you will uh understand that
first of all on the green deal you
probably still have to explain your own
group that the green deal is the jobs
deal they still don't get that
so work to be done there as well but
also in your own college i have the
feeling that that some of your
colleagues are feeling a bit like oh
after fit for 55 our work is done the
work is only begunning and for example
on stay date we do expect also that here
the commission is delivering so i'm
looking also at madame vestager for that
on corona vaccination it was a bit too
self-congratulatory
because the global vaccination that is
our key challenge now and here kovacs is
not enough mentioning a state of the
union without using the word patent is a
bit of a problem and last point on the
rule of law you absolutely had good
words on that but now you have to apply
the instruments that you have since the
first of january because the rule of law
is really our basis of a european union
with the soul that you want thank you
very much
thank you mr eichhout next is peter
covford for one minute
thank you very much
madam president
your
speech dealt with an eu strategy
for
military forces cooperation in the eu
and financing proposals
which
lead to onerous eu own resources and
taxes so they weren't described as such
in
your speech
i think we need to be very
thorough here the commission wants to
intervene even
more when it comes to
asylum seekers we didn't invite and we
don't want
you were talking about trust
president of the commission yes indeed
but i don't trust the commission the
president and the whole system
because
we see a police a policy which is
creating chaos and migration cannot be
stopped
confidence
thank you madam president president
vanderlian
who i can't see
let's move away from dreams and let's
move to reality
the idea of a common debt to finance the
recovery is a good idea but the delays
and the political conditions working
against governments that don't give into
the dictates of the commission
is bad as is the attempt to do away with
austerity which could mean the recovery
is not a success
what we would have wanted was more
impetus for the real economy instead
what we have is a green ideology of the
green deal which will be
unsustainable for our companies and make
us more dependent on china rather than
moving to strategic autonomy
defense of external borders instead of
uncontrolled migration would have been
better instead what we're seeing is very
few returns and records of arrivals
internationally after afghanistan all we
have is a flow of refugees and we have
more fundamentalism we need a
different europe doing less but better
respecting the sovereignty of national
states that's the only europe that will
actually work
for one minute
thank you madam president
in order to achieve the objectives that
mr miss fonder lion
outlined in her presentation we need to
be
bold in what we do
not only words five priorities
serious changes in the stability pact
for
deficits and debts in order to
strengthen social cohesion and to avoid
a new debt crisis and savage austerity
in the south
bolder measures and more funds to reduce
social inequality disparities which are
increasingly and dangerously uh
growing
stop
tax evasion of big companies more
ambitious objectives
for in order to deal with climate change
as science requests and a stronger
community budget with new owned
resources
fine words are not enough we need bold
deeds thank you
one minute
[Music]
didn't you know miss uh vonderlion that
the speech on the state of union
aimed
to
give us a realistic picture of the eu
that was the idea but look
at
the
uh
we have the fact that we have a
slovenian presidency three countries
accused of
corruption
[Music]
four
million
unexplained
money on
a private family account
so the eu seems to be a way of shifting
tax money to the private economy
the
state of the union would be best
described by saying that in germany we
don't talk about the eu but in the eu
talks about germany
i do
apologize to all uh citizens that the
uh
interests of the german economy
have
[Music]
been uh destroyed and i'm sure this will
continue to happen in the coming decades
eva mydel for two minutes
president i should like to thank you for
your speech
i think that europe now needs to be
visionary but it also needs security and
stability until it manages to leave
behind the different crisis in which it
has found itself as you have said crises
have always been our strongest allies
because they make us develop they give
us a painful signal of our mistakes and
what we need to change this is how we
have created many of our institutions
which have made our union stronger today
but my question is did europe learn its
lesson of the refugee crisis of 1915
have we forgotten what the crisis had
inflicted on our union have we forgotten
the fears it
embedded in our societies have we
forgotten it turned into a fuel into the
engine of extreme populists after 2019
and the elections results we seem to
have forgotten this
after what has happened in afghanistan
all these unlearned lessons may turn
into a tremendous failure for europe now
we are welcoming people who are much
more foreign to our culture but we need
much more protection so we need to
assess who can be accepted and who
cannot
our borders
can become
borders under tremendous pressure but
have we protected them
we need a real
border protection from frontex
states like bulgaria greece malta will
again face the major inflows have we
changed the doubling regulation in order
to distribute more evenly the burden
will bulgaria greece and cyprus and
again turn into the wounds of europe do
we have a plan europe will look and
serious unless it learns from its own
experience and i hope all the
institutions will do that
madam president since 2019 your
commission has made important steps
forward with the green deal and the
health strategy and we would
welcome that but the pandemic isn't just
an isolated health crisis as you know
we're at in the heart of a metacrisis of
the capitalist system economic social
environmental political crisis the major
challenge is to solve these crises and
that will only happen if we start
questioning everything and if we act
resolutely
because
there are limits and constraints on the
planetary resources that have to be
taken into account
our group in parliament has already put
forward a first series of robust
political proposals
including reform of tax rules social
rights human rights
genuine
transformation of the way in which we
live and assess our lives not just
basing everything on gdp but on
well-being but we also need to reinforce
the strategic autonomy of the eu
and the multilateral trade system also
needs to be reformed through the wto
we need a genuine transformation of our
food and agri-food systems as well as
our economic and social and
environmental systems
that's how we will have equality between
men and women we need a world agenda
for the sdgs of the un to be put into
place and it's based on that whether our
group will decide whether the commission
is up to the task facing both europe and
humanity as a whole
i now give the floor to vice president
nicolabel for two minutes
europa canyon
europe can keep its head above water yes
it can make contributions to solve
crises yes it can do that but that's not
enough europe is too slow and often
takes circuitous routes europe we must
get better this is what people want in
this united europe
the pandemic has shown that europe is
not going under but europe is not doing
anything world changing or
groundbreaking that we need to change
that commission of underlying we need to
move from being a crisis manager to the
political avant-garde of the west that
needs to be our ambition the foreign
security policy debacle in afghanistan
has showed us mercilessly how helpless
europe is and not just there in the
eastern flank of europe
putin is flexing his muscles together
with a belarus regime which has nothing
to lose that shows us that in terms of
foreign
defense policy
europe is at the side table we need to
move from being a union of speeches and
announcements to a union of actions we
need to
achieve genuine strength now or never
it's the time to formulate this
political compass this political new
start and we need to implement it we
need to do this in the conference on the
future of europe that should not be an
end in itself or a job creation exercise
it is urgent and it is a priority
being forges of talent through
innovation education research
and manage migration of skilled labor
and we should be the number one
for sustainable and
competitive
industrial locations we need to find a
european answer to china's appetite for
power and influence we need to be
a human rights advocate to be taken
seriously let's tackle the reforms if
necessary with treaty changes let's take
these possibilities let us change the
world in word and deed
two years ago
i was hoping
that the term of this commission would
be time for development and not the time
for maintaining status quo that it would
be the time of civil society and the
people of science and not the time of
lobbyists
the list of tasks is long violence
against women
the rights of lgbtq people and the
climate
catastrophe this catastrophe calls for
ambitious objectives and quick
actions for two years people of science
researchers have been calling upon the
commission to do so europe must be
courageous dealing with transport with
energy sector does not call for
courage the courage is necessary
to
state that also agriculture is to blame
we need courage to stand up to the meter
lobby and we should really start the
real reform of the common agriculture
policy if mr timmermans and mr
wojciechowski lack this courage then
maybe they should resign
we don't have time thank you
marcus only now three minutes
grazie
thank you
president president vandalian
we listened carefully to your speech
and i will try and bring out
the points you made
first of all the most urgent issues the
response to covid and the economic
crisis
i think there is too much complacency
in the commission's words in the words
you used
i wouldn't describe today's situation as
a success there has been a change of
direction of course that you came
to us to this parliament in january
acknowledging mistakes but today not
enough has been done we have to thank
the states
who have really set the machinery in
place
for vaccination which isn't really the
merit of the european commission
correcting a course is really something
to think about rather than be complacent
about and then when it comes to economic
recovery
quite
you
talked about the next generation eu
let's look at what it is
the first funds that came in a year and
a half after the crisis time has been
lost
and we're a long way behind in terms of
jobs of getting back to pre-pandemic
levels and then there's a new subject
defense
you have launched a project which will
be discussed i think the
western faucets
already exist in nato
you cannot do without the uk in
cooperation with the
usa
there's always the problem with money
all too often
we've benefited from the umbrella of the
our american allies and the states
haven't done their duty to
invest in defense and you our former
defense minister i'm sure you're very
well aware of this on the
green issues
the green deal a lot of work has been
done on this
but i think we've had enough of
ideological approaches we need
pragmatism
the transition
that the
commission
has constructed is a transition for the
wealthy it's not the right one it's not
an ecological transition
which well it should not be weighing on
the shoulders of the least well off and
president timomans is number two in your
commission
which you talked about as a political
commission
now it's the politicians who have to
decide how to redistribute the costs of
the transition
now on subjects of the future of
integration
we're discussing this
today we are all aware that there is a
need to reform the union people have
different ideas may i make a suggestion
i think we've had enough
of in
forcing the citizens sit we need to
convince and persuade the citizens you
cannot push forward a political project
by forcing the citizens
[Music]
for one minute
thank you madam chair madam president of
commission colleagues the state of union
can be described in one sentence it
would be
comical if it was not tragic we have a
few crises facing us migrants economic
and health instead of solving them the
union deals in economic lobbyism called
green deal and
issues calls that are against the
traditional family and something new and
something revolutionary in this uh mr
timmermans congratulations for your mask
it shows that you care for this truly
important issues while the european
union is dealing in this our competitors
are developing and making progress
in china the works are the the factories
are working and are selling as cheap and
uh
they're attracting our own working force
this happens because when there are uh
weak politicians they create difficult
times and the policy your
leading madam president is weak you
cannot choose the um
prevalence of law we cannot
give promotion to human rights this fact
this union will become strong if it goes
back to its roots
the christian family zero migration and
protection of self-identity
thank you
citizens madame van der lion
your report on the status of the basic
and fundamental rights of our citizens
is contrary to the actual situation
during the past 80 years since nazism
we've never had such a situation
where fundamental human rights are being
trampled upon
freedom of movement
right to work
the right to prevent
medical tests and experiments on 500
million of eu citizens it is the right
of every citizen to make decision about
his health his life and his freedom of
movement
we we have gone back on several
centuries of development of medicine
now we request medical certificates
meaning
that those who are vaccinated have
freedom of movement although
they can
infect others this is crazy you need to
put an end to it thank you
president mitsula president vanderlian
the
speech from the president of the
commission does show the
differences of the european union
it was a positive speech it was
optimistic it was encouraging it has the
support of the epp group and the
portuguese members of that group
you strongly defended rule of law
particularly when it comes to funds when
it comes to the budget
but it's not enough to guarantee that
funds are dispersed when we have respect
for the eu's values we have to guarantee
that those funds are well spent
well
disbursed that they won't go to mega
projects
to vanity projects
that
they go to clientelist interests and
that's why it's so important that we
have control of funds to ensure they are
well spent
we have a plan to re-launch the economy
to relaunch companies to provide
opportunities to young people and to
increase
inter-generational solidarity
not to prop up the operating expenses of
the budget in certain countries
including my own
and not to be used as an electoral
campaigning weapon as happens in my
government
the european recovery plan isn't a
national one it's a european plan for
all europeans and the european
commission needs to pay attention to
this ensuring funds are properly used
for the digital transition for the green
transition for the modernization of
economies
and therefore for prosperity and for
growth
and here madam president a great deal of
attention needs to be paid to a vital
point at this point in time the price of
energy
is
unacceptable for companies and for
families
we need an ambitious green transition
we need an ambitious digital transition
but it has to be socially sustainable
and
we
hope for that as europeans as companies
as individuals we support the commission
in its efforts thank you
a half minute
thank you
chair madam president commissioners
in the last one year and a half we all
lived under the dark shadow of covet-19
crisis
but europe withstood it we did fairly
well
however
now we're entering the most important uh
period the period of delivery
because we have an unprecedented
instrument in our hands this is the next
generation eu recovery package
but we
need to work hard in order to make it a
success and there are three major
criteria and preconditions to make it
happen
first we don't need to come to the
situation before the crisis
we need the recovery to lead to a
sustainable
development economy and society for
europe both
environmentally and socially second
if we want the green and the digital
transitions to be successful we need to
provide the tools that it is just
and we need resources in order to make
the buffers and protect those who will
suffer
thirdly
rule of law and democracy are paramount
importance for the socialists you now as
commission have all the instruments to
provide them in the use of the resources
of the fund so please use them if we
follow these three preconditions and
criteria i think that in one year we
shall be even more optimistic about the
future thank you very much
thank you uh very much next is sophie
and develop for one and a half minutes
thank you madam chair
president von lay and you have today
presented a list of ambitious plans but
in its current state the european union
cannot deliver
we support most of your plans
wholeheartedly but intergovernmental
europe is sclerotic and paralyzed and
the european council has become the
graveyard of many crucial initiatives
migration pact stuck geopolitics europe
is a [ __ ] rule of law talk talk no
action and europe is quietly but
steadily losing ground in the global
economy
the green deal is a great plan but
national governments have already
started to unpick and pick it
you mentioned rightfully the lack of
political will but let me finish that
sentence for you the lack of political
will of the national governments
yet the commission is making itself the
most loyal servant of the council while
community europe has been losing ground
but dear colleagues let's also look at
ourselves
if the commission is cozying up to the
council it's because it smells where the
power is
and it is up to this house to restore
the democratic balance the separation of
powers and checks and balances
parliament should not just be a good
legislator but also take its tasks as
parliamentary watchdog more seriously
because our ambitions the ambitions that
we share cannot be made reality with a
limping democracy and this house has
therefore to drastically up its game in
the next couple of years because only a
strong political union can take europe
forward thank you
thank you miss and fell to next is sven
gigold for one minute
come on
of the commission colleagues europe's
green deal is without any doubt the
greatest climate protection program that
an eu
commission has ever proposed for a whole
continent but after this crisis summer
we need more speed and more ambition
these are central problems uh the
problem is not a lack of notifications
from brussel but
but a lack of action on the part of
member states looking at germany i see a
great gap
between german ambitions and european
ambitions in climate policy
the
german government wants to postpone
measures it has not
implemented the text on renewables and
with nordstream it's going the wrong way
so germany is
putting the brakes on uh europe uh
europe's climate policy and that's why
for european climate protection we also
need a german federal
uh government
that can act for climate protection
thank you mr gilgold next is christian
terres for one minute
thank you
the president from the lion in 2019 as a
candidate for the office that you are
holding right now
you said in this plenary and i quote the
foundation of our european civilization
is greek philosophy and roman law
what you did not mention
in that speech is the founder is the
fundamental role that christianity and
implicitly the judeo-christian values
had in developing the european
civilization based on these christian
values and the belief that all human
beings are created in the image of god
the fundamental and inalienable rights
were developed which later was specified
in treaties and conventions as well as
national constitutions and laws
reducing the european civilization only
to greek philosophy and roman law and
ignoring the judeo-christian values
you'll find arguments for inequality and
slavery as he was in the ancient greeks
greek and tyranny as he was in the
ancient rome
under your dealership unfortunately the
european union became from an area of
freedom a concentration camp in which
people cannot travel eating restaurants
or go to movies unless they have a green
certificate i urge you therefore to
promote and defend in the european union
the christian heritage and values based
on which well are created by god equal
and born free thank you thank you mr
there has next is dorian rockmaker for
one minute
thank you chair
today the president of the european
commission set out the agenda for the
coming year
the agenda is hyper ambitious
the president speaks of the team eu but
we have never been more divided
action is reaction
if the commission tries to force member
states with legal actions
it will only create more opposition
you may not like or trust orban or
morowitzki
but the majority of voters do
and we have to
respect democracy
second transparency is key
every you eu citizen should be able to
see what's going on
the technique is available we can start
tomorrow
finally to create a real working union
we must connect in real life
free movement of persons by high-speed
rail
that creates a world of opportunity for
all
it's green it's accessible and it's safe
respect transparency and tangible
results
this will bring europe closer together
thank you
next is
esther de lange for one and a half
minutes
madam president you mentioned the floods
you mentioned the fires that occurred
this summer and said we need to act
together against climate change
the netherlands fortunately had no
fatalities but the damage caused was
huge
companies individuals were faced with
floods households that believed that
they were insured
found that the insurance companies
refused to pay out schools had to be
evacuated
madam president of the commission i'm
not making an appeal to you per se the
european commission has acted it's more
an appeal really to the dutch government
for them to use the funds being made
available european house to our european
union and in many areas indeed that
house is strong we added an extra room
in the area of health when we face an
unprecedented health threats
but the house also needs a strong
foundation the rule of law independent
courts and independent media i thank the
commission for the initiatives announced
in this area today but like the pandemic
the rule of law is not a sprint but a
marathon and this house expects the
european commission to go all the way
and let me
finalize
today's
contribution by saying that we also need
fixing our roof when it's not yet
raining i'm thinking about the creation
of a capital markets union the
completion of the banking union how
matter
no matter how difficult that will be so
let's get to work thank you
thank you
very much
mr lange next is brando benife
thank you president
president
from
[Music]
lyon what would the founding fathers of
european
integration say looking at the last 20
years with the explosion of
globalization the attack on the twin
towers afghanistan they would say how
much time has been lost while the world
went on
but
today we're finally on the right track
the disasters we've seen have led to a
re
reaction we're now seeing
attempts to reform budget rules
cooling at debt the construction of a
social europe technological sovereignty
ecological transition humanitarian
corridors common defense and lgbt rights
women's rights on all these subjects
you've used courageous
words
madam president the parliament
needs to do its part
it may seem impossible to have a europe
of solidarity and democracy but it is
possible it needs to be done thank you
next
thank you
president of the commission miss van der
lion
you gave us a fine speech
a speech full of hope
and
it stuck with me i heard your passion
speaking from the heart
for europe but there was something
missing in your speech you were minister
of defense you
stand up for
defense
and security for europe
but you seem to be too shy you're not
going far enough
[Music]
towards a european army it has to be
done now
if we don't take this step now towards a
european army then when are we going to
do it we spend a lot of money on
european defense but each
member state on its own we we spend as
much as china more than russia i'm not
saying anything against uh
nato i agree with stoltenberg
a a strong european pillar in nato will
help us and i talked to gifa hofstadt
one of the uh topics being
that has to be discussed in the
conference on the future of europe is a
european army
so i'm saying
have courage
take that step
use your power and move towards a
european army
meyer for one minute and a half
thank you very much madam chair madam
presidents dear colleagues dear guests
i guess we can be very proud for things
we have done
last year i just hope
we
save more lives
reduce the suffering and save some costs
but now we must face the future
and here i must say that i share an
agree the agenda the program presented
by you madame president commented by
manfred weber and the others and unlike
a lot of people in this house i believe
we can deliver on this program if we
want
let me share some points that were
discussed and i haven't heard a lot
a reaction in discussion first on
microchips here i guess time is money
and we must find a way how to help our
researchers investors and firms to
increase our sovereignty and support our
economy the example to follow is not
just galileo it's also battery alliance
that i guess is doing very well
second i was very pleased to hear that
human rights are not for sale as you
said at no cost
i guess yesterday was too late to make
it more real i guess to start with ban
on certain export is the first step but
just the first step and i guess we must
believe on that finally last not least
let me refer to next generation eu and
rrf i guess this was a very right
decision in the right time let me just
remind commission and cancer that there
should be no space only not for
corruption conflict of interest and
wrongdoing but we must make sure that
money will deliver that's the key how to
turn this brave decision into success
thank you
thank you mr neither meyer next is
javier moreno sanchez for one minute
thank you madam president
mazam vandalian ladies and gentlemen the
state of the union has improved over
this year thanks to the collective
efforts made by everybody
europe
is still a convalescent but it's moving
to overcome the crisis and towards
economic recovery with the vaccination
campaign and the initiating of the
recovery plan
europe therefore
is
going back to looking to the future a
green environmentalist feminist future
with a transition that needs to be fair
in territorial terms amongst states and
socially amongst all citizens
but ladies and gentlemen the crisis
caused by the pandemic was of such an
extent
that the same rules won't work and that
goes for the economic sphere too which
is why i agree with minister calvinia's
proposals that green and digital
investment shouldn't count as part of
the deficit or the debt of member states
and that the recovery fund should be
permanent please let's go down that path
thank you
next is benoit woodgen for an minute
madam president
without you without the commission no
member state would have been able to
vaccinate so many of its citizens
without you without the commission
no member state would have been able to
give such intensity of support to its
workers and businesses without you
today there will be no recovery plan
in the various member states without you
the climate ambition would not have been
raised and that was really necessary
through our common action
as you said this morning
we needed to
give it priority
to the european youth wherever they live
even if it's
in
really run down areas or in the back of
beyond
that's our ambition
and that is where we will sow the seeds
of european values which unite us that
creates our european dignity it makes
sense in terms of the policy
we
carry out over the next few
weeks and months
this will enable young people to get
jobs
training
and
obviously
we need to take action this is part of
responsibility solidarity and
it's part of your courage and your
enthusiasm thank you
next is jensgayer for one minute
thank you for president
thank you madam
president of underlying i won't repeat
what colleagues from my group have said
on a social dimension rule of law and
migration i think the
commission's proposals have come too
late and
lack ambition
let's not be too late with the political
industrial
challenges
we are now
dependent on
on the outside which is a great
shortcoming we need to recreate our own
capacities let's be quicker with that
fair conditions needs a supply chain law
thank you
for
the work done on that but there's also
the
lack of
protection for workers and ban on child
labour which would also help to protect
european jobs
i now give the floor to carlo wrestler
for one minute and a half
madam president
of the commission dear colleagues
the complexity of
climate
uh demographic and economic uh
challenges
requires a reaction
uh to the situation generated by a
crisis without precedent we can see what
is going
on
children are going back to schools there
are cultural and sporting events and
member states are have started to
receive
record resources for modernization this
is why we support
uh the
the recovery and resilience uh plan and
it has the support of our citizens as
well we have to prepare ourselves
for the new digital era because this is
also one of the goals of the recovering
resilience uh plans
we must become more resilient and more
ready to react in extraordinary
situations one of which
we have witnessed this summer from
natural disasters and humanitarian
crises and hybrid attacks on our borders
we also have to reduce disparities in
europe and support societies
which are ready to take new
steps my country is a good example of
that as the youngest eu member state
croatia is ready to join schengen and we
are coming
closer and closer to introducing euro
these are both national and european
achievements and this is uh the
direction that uh should be supported
without any doubt thank you
much mr wrestler next is agnes your hair
use for one minute
thank you for hitting
thank you madam president president van
der lyon
the
hawks in the netherlands are on the rise
you for a year have been talking about
support for the member states and for
recovery
and resilience and let's hope that we
will have new budget rules
which will make it possible to do
everything we need to do
that will be vital for the climate
agreement to be
successful but also to ensure that we
can support our citizens hopefully the
capital markets will continue to support
all of this but hopefully whilst showing
solidarity when we talk about
sustainability
i'd like to draw attention to social
sustainability
without a doubt
um an ever more european mobility
package
is vital that requires
flexible contracts with not too many
requirements on
employers or employees so i would ask
you to put that into your program
thank you
congratulations president
on a very fine speech one hour in
duration during which you didn't drop a
note so to speak
i think it is only right that you should
refer to cover 19 and the successful
vaccine deployment in the eu
the need to be prepared for future
pandemics
and eu's help to tart countries
i was also encouraged to hear your words
on digitalization semiconductors and
carbon neutral economy
i noticed
you never mentioned the b word brexit
perhaps an intelligent omission and a
message in itself
but as the only irish mep
speaking in this debate
i would like to take this opportunity
to praise the steady practical and
mature approach taken by you by the
commission and especially the diligent
and ongoing work of vice president
safkovic negotiating and finalizing our
future relationship with the uk
the eu must create mechanisms to engage
with civil society and political
structures in northern ireland to ensure
that the protocol works and i know we'll
have your full support for that madam
when appropriate i intend to lead a
trade delegation of meps to northern
ireland to hear the views of those on
the ground those who are actually
affected we have a responsibility to
listen and to try to solve the problems
and we must not take this responsibility
lightly finally
a pet team of mine daylight savings at
president juncker tried to end in this
outmoded practice perhaps you could
finalize that thank you very much
thank you very much mr kelly next is
robert biederon for one minute
madam president when i'm president
by the way i think it's super cool that
two women are leading this debate today
thank you very much keep fingers crossed
thank you
said that europe needs soul
uh madam president you've said that this
soul is in the rule of law if it is true
then i would like to call upon you to
act
what the commission has done so far on
the rule of law is insufficient
half
of the term is
behind us and
we have the deterioration of the rule of
law in poland in 30 percent of our
country we have lgbtq free zones
polish women have less rights
less rights than when we
access the european union we have also
the shrinking
media freedoms
in poland
we need decisive actions on the part of
the commission
if it is not sufficient i think it is
high time european commission uh put
forward a special a package
on the better protection of the rule of
law and individual member states i would
like to appeal to you once again madam
president before i pass the floor to mr
histoforou i will now move to
today's first voting session we will
vote on the files as indicated on the
agenda
the first voting session will be open
from 1300 until 1415
and the same voting method will be used
as during the previous voting sessions
all votes will be held by roll call
i declare therefore the voting sessions
open and you have until quarter past two
to vote and the results
of the first voting sessions will be
announced at seven o'clock this evening
also in relation to the decisions by the
israel and econ committees to enter into
inter-institutional negotiations
pursuant to rule 71 paragraph one as
announced at the opening of the session
on monday 13th of september the
president has received no requests for a
vote in parliament by members or
political groups reaching at least the
medium threshold the committees may
therefore start the negotiation so now
the floor over to you mr histo forum for
one minute and a half
president madam president of the
european commission i fully
agree with the european vision and the
european values because i am
fully convinced that the european union
is in favor of
and promotes the
aspirations of european people that is
the greatest
achievement of mankind in the last 75
years i cannot imagine any other way to
deal with the pandemic the climate
change and all of the other crises
without the european union
the
we have now a
perspective for growth
jobs and
a good economy what i am asking for now
is a strong a leading european union a
leader among
everybody else around the globe but
greece and cyprus at the same time are
suffering on a daily basis the
provocations the threats
of their sovereign rights by turkey and
the eu instead of condemning this it is
calling turkey its strategic partner it
is time for the european union to
declare that the sovereign rights of
of the eu and of its member states are
non-negotiable that they should not be
influenced by turkey or nobody else i
fully agree with you that human rights
are not for sale and they're
non-negotiable but i'm asking my
huma my own human right to return to the
place where i was born to my home
because i one one of the
thousands of greek cypriot refugees how
is this defended of course we defend
human rights around the globe but the
time has come to tell european citizens
how we support their human rights in
order for us to create the europe that
we wish to create a sovereign europe
that will be able to tackle the
challenges of our times we will all be
proud of it thank you very much
finn thank you colleague christopher s
thank you mr pizzulo is next
madam president
since your last year's state of the
union address
uh vaccines have been
developed um the recovery and resilience
plans have have been
prepared and we have better economic
results when it comes to croatia i have
to say that there are some specificities
last year croatia was hit by a strong
earthquake
and there is fear that the resources
from the recovering resilience uh
resilience fund might go under use
because this is the responsibility of
national gov governments we need to
remove barriers among us i'm talking
about schengen i ask you to support
croatia's entry into the schengen area
this would definitely improve our
economic cooperation and improve the
well-being of citizens when it comes to
the enlargement process it is a pity
that you didn't speak more about it in
your address you said that we are
sharing the same destiny of the west
balkans this is why we have to
remove the harmful blockages and support
this process thank you
thank you mr pizzler
next is mr hansen for one and a half
minutes president dear madam president
if you had told us one year ago during
your state of the union 2020 that when
you would stand before us again 70
of the eu population would have been
vaccinated
who would have believed you
and it is a tremendous success of the eu
and one that makes it very clear the the
health union we need it more than ever
but while the youth capacity protects uh
to protect its citizens from future and
current pandemics um uh is slowly coming
of age our vet politics guide like
jean-claude juncker used to call it
still remains stuck in infancy all too
often the used voice comes late and is
not credible without the capacity to
back our own commitments as we have seen
it very clearly in the evacuation of our
citizens from the airport in kabul to
become credible with open strategic
autonomy we must give ourselves the
means to enforce our rules for all
players in our single market european or
not for example with the tool to combat
distortive
foreign subsidies in the single market
and the tool to demand reciprocity such
as in public procurement these are the
conditions necessary to guarantee that
our openness remains a strength rather
than weakness and finally madam
president we need a fully fledged china
task force to finally and once and for
all be able to speak with one voice
towards china and finally as well thank
you for the import ban on
forced labour goods thank you very much
thank you mr hansen
mr zarinia one minute
madam president
we have to learn from lessons
a solidarity in our response to the
crisis
is the difference between the response
given to the last crisis and that shows
how important it is that the path we
have is based on solarity and moving
towards a union a union of health
a union of strategic autonomy
a fiscal union
where we are fighting for sustainability
for the planet and dignity for human
beings a union of health common defense
where we have fair trade where we have
gender equality where we have a union
against violence against energy poverty
i do hope madam president that we've
learned from the lessons of the past
when we actually
change our governance model as you
announced we have to show solidarity we
have to show cooperation we have to
avoid as well economic chokeholds
because they will lead to injustice
between people and economic poverty
thank you
[Music]
colleague
thank you mr sorry
mrs niebler is next
thank you very much president president
of the commission representative of
council colleagues
there are two comments i would like to
make on the state of the union first of
all on corona crisis management and what
the eu has achieved
in this very difficult time i think it
was not bad
commission president you in your speech
talked about youth and i think that's
excellent because during the pandemic we
have spoken far too little about young
people and uh what we have demanded of
them
during this time i'm glad that the alma
program is uh up and running and that
we're investing
in
training education and further training
of young people and
that we're doing everything we can to
offer possibilities to young people
second comment is about the geopolitical
role of the union and the commission
that was one of your core uh
points when you took uh on the post of
commission president and you talked
about afghanistan i'm wondering if not
now then when
will we strengthen the european pillar
in nato if not now then when
will we continue to develop our cfsp
i think it's very important to
put all our political will
and power
into that if we want to be taken
seriously on the global scene not just
as a strong economic power but also
on the subject of security i think
that's the big task
facing us over the next two and a half
years to really make progress with that
and and to give our citizens what they
deserve
thank you mrs nibbler
one minute mr negrescu
president colleagues in order to discuss
about the state of the union we need to
know and to understand the state of the
european citizens the pandemics the
discrepancies
the decrease in levels of living make it
very difficult for citizens to live
the political instability and we
governance as the case in romania which
was ignored in your speech need concrete
actions prompt actions and this is why
we need the european union to get
involved in new domains education must
become a priority all european citizens
must be able to learn in good decent
conditions no child can be left behind
if you want to
focus on the future of europe i urge you
to construct a europe of education an
educated europe is
more powerful able to respond to the
challenges i suggest that we should have
a global summit on education and to
focus on an increase of investments in
this domain i count on you to make
education a priority for the european
union thank you
thank you mr negrescu
mr bullman is next for one minute
president
madam president of the commission madame
funder lion
you came at the start of your mandate
saying that you wanted to lead a global
commission which would meet the
challenges of the age
and would make sure
that we can
make these challenges manageable
with an important role for the european
union
so i think your ambition
is correct
and needs to be pursued but how far
have we come
in achieving what we want to achieve yes
internally we're better
when it comes to covid but people are
dying all over the world i'm not saying
we can do everything alone but we need
to
lead a coalition
tax policy we had a unique chance
to put an end to
tax
evasion tax havens
but we need to be serious you and when
it comes to values you were talking
about dialogue the steps in poland
are
important but when will our patients end
with mr orban when will we take the
necessary measures
thank you mr bulman
for one minute mr lopet aguilar is next
gracias
thank you president president fonder
lion
i would endorse everything that the head
of our group said in this house but i do
agree with two things that you said you
urge the european parliament to
legislate asap
on the new migration and asylum pact
because it will only be a pact when the
ep takes it on board and that's when we
can guarantee
binding solidarity with
migrants and asylum seekers
and
it's absolutely vital we do this
to protect them when they come into
countries that have external borders
with the rest of the world whether we're
talking about the atlantic or the
mediterranean the asylum system was
suggested by the commission in 2016
and so council really does need to move
forward on this rule of law you said
that we need to guarantee the respect of
rule of law and the
judgments of the court of justice i
totally agree but let's recall
that you didn't mention by name
hungary and poland and article 7
proceedings and we are prepared to use
article 8785 of the treaty to ensure
speaker is cut off
thank you mr lopez aguilar
mrs kutaya is next do you have one
minute
i am proud to bring to this debate the
perspective of molten gotzo two islands
that might seem far away from the center
but are profoundly european and ready
not only to be a bridge between the
union and our mediterranean partners but
also beyond i must state that i welcome
the emphasis on social justice and
work-life balance you are right madam
president this pandemic has taught us
how precious time is a europe that truly
cares about social rights is one that
would bring equality amongst its
citizens and the diverse regions within
our member states we must ensure a
bright future for our youths i do
greatly welcome the upcoming european
year of youth and the special program
for the unemployed and unskilled youths
because everyone deserves to experience
eu opportunities finally i welcome the
commission's recognition of malta's
efforts in strengthening the rule of law
together let's continue strengthening
journalistic protection and our rights
thank you
thank you
thank you mr kutaya
on behalf of the commission i will give
the floor to the president
from the lion
thank you
i'm not that small
vice president ladies and gentlemen
members
thank you for such a diverse and lively
debate and first of all let me make it
clear
some uh have said that we're getting
close to half time in our mandate no the
commission has been in this uh
office for uh 20 months we've got two
thirds to go and every month
and every day every hour will be made
use of to move europe forwards this
debate has shown and it's impressive
that a large majority is there
with the willingness to implement and
that is the task that we need to
overcome
we have many legislative files on the
table and we need to make sure
that we make progress i know
that the legislation will be changed
when it emerges from
negotiations but the tasks are so uh
urgent
that we can't just uh
leave them uh
to lie now if you think about the fight
against climate change we know we don't
have much time
and that's why it's so important for us
to offer our response and our
obligation
to
combat climate change i know it's a
massive task the package is there but
it's also a big opportunity
to bring influence to bear for
improvement because we all feel that we
can't continue
in this way
robbing nature so let's
tackle this task with
energy and the european passion that i
know you have our single market is
recovering well because for the very
first time in such a harsh crisis
we have managed
to create unity in the union all levels
are cooperating towards the same goal we
have no
inter-governmental
agreement this time we manage with next
generation eu to get everyone unified
behind one single goal to invest
to
stop this threatening crisis and to use
investment to accelerate recovery and on
purpose we called it next generation eu
because the philosophy is that with this
money and this is quite right because we
don't want to
hamper
the economy and create unemployment no
on the country one we want investment to
trigger the economy
so with that money we need to make sure
it's invested in such a way that it's
the next generation that benefits youth
and that's the big subject fight against
climate change now when i look at where
we stand now we have a record
speed with this program and we see that
18
member states have now completed their
negotiations and the program is running
two have not yet submitted what's
important for us is that two principles
be fulfilled in this program first of
all investments yes but hand in hand
with reforms
and
in conjunction with the important issue
of rule of law
i have heard many good points
many justified
requirements
and
there was
one
person who asked a question
unfortunately that person is not here to
hear the answer but i'll still give the
answer
what do we want to do with rule of law
well we it's very simple it's very clear
these principles are in the treaties of
the european union and in the charter of
fundamental rights that is where you can
find the answers and the
commission is the guardian of these
treaties we've got the article 7
procedure
the violation of the treaty
proceedings which can lead to sanctions
and we have made use of that possibility
and then the reports on uh
rule of law and the conditionality
mechanism i can confirm that when we
talk about
protecting our budget we will do
whatever we can whatever is within our
power to do so and i can announce that
in the coming weeks
the first written notifications will be
sent out the same person who asked the
question
also asked where is the basis and the
rules
for next generation eu they're also
clearly laid out in legislation so apart
from investment we've got these forms
the uh
the country specific recommendations and
those recommendations need to be
implemented in the reform mechanism
and if the independence of justice in
the country specific uh recommendations
are contained within then we need to see
the reforms that make that possible
until we've got that we cannot conclude
and if in those country-specific
recommendations as a call
to fight against corruption then we
attempted we would take uh steps
in uh we want to see those steps in the
national recovery plans otherwise we
cannot agree to those recovery plans
that's the phase we're in at the moment
and
members of parliament
i know that we have
many more issues uh on the agenda that
was my short answer uh thank you for
being here thank you
for your energy and the willingness to
implement that i've been able to feel
today these are all
issues that are uh
essential for
the future of europe and for young
people and i know that you will join in
our struggle to improve
the future of europe for young people
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much commissioner van der
luyn
miss poncetti obvious is next for one
minute
thank you president
president ryan
the recommendations of the country of
europe regarding spain had a very long
list of homeworks
that has not been followed and you are
silent about it the spanish government
has taken no action to stop repression
and end judicial abuse just a few days
ago a spokesman for the spanish popular
party was boasting in the newspaper
interview that his party has the support
of the majority of a judiciary and no
one seems uncomfortable about this
authoritarian judges on an anti-catalan
crusade do the dirty work for mr pedro
sanchez
looking away from the elephant in the
room will not work and it is costly as
long as europe announces its obligation
to check on spain's authoritarian and
illegal tendencies europe is bound to
become the alibi for any bully that
needs one
let it be morocco turkey russia saudi
arabia also the powers of asia
spain is the achilles heel of the eu its
national insecurity that needs to crush
all popularity is the back door for the
torii italianism spreading to european
institutions do not let this happen
under your watch thank you very much
thank you
the next speaker is mr scherdivan
for one minute
thank you very much president thank you
very much for the discussion president
of the commission
well
what remains from this debate about the
state of the union a lot of buzzwords
but no convincing ideas i'd like to help
you out
there i think we need to develop the eu
as an area of social protection you
spoke about
the um workers in the front line working
against the pandemic these people need
more than applause they need better
working conditions
higher wages
and
they need better services and
uh social security that's what the
population wants i'm speaking for them
rather than just the parliament and then
you need to tackle monopolies open
the
market for smes
data protection is important you need to
bring about a process of digital
convention and when it comes to climate
protection
the there needs to be social flanking to
climate measures that's my idea my
proposal for a european union
of social protection thank you thank you
very much mr shirdivan
mr ross is next for one minute
thank you president
the european union should be a
practical complement to europe and it is
when the right situations right
decisions are taken
but what we're seeing is economic
decisions creating bubbles and
we're also seeing our children having
problems in
paying for housing we need to ensure
that the rules are actually followed in
the
stability and growth pack because that
stimulates positive economies we need to
encourage the use of good nuclear energy
without reducing co2 emissions nature is
what enables us to provide a future
we need security of supply
and
that means that we need the right energy
prices we need to protect our borders we
need to be able to teach our children to
be critical at school we need in
conclusion to respect the union the
sovereignty of the union the union is
made up of 27 states and diversity
amongst themselves thank you
thank you mr moyeton is next for one
minute
one minute three short
thoughts
this uh house applauds the new own
resources that your proposal proposing
that it we should be protesting
i'm quite perplexed uh
anyway second idea uh youth
should be
free
and not bound
by different programs let them get on
with it they can do it without the eu
they can manage better alone
unfortunately i see people
leaving our countries
they don't go to eu
member states many
well
educated
young people are leaving the eu third
idea what about the
about nature i believe that you want to
prevent damage but you need to change
your strategy it's not going to work
with wind energy it's not going to work
with immobility you need to
think about a different strategy
it's not working we're not going to be
able to
secure our energy supply we're robbing
nature thank you
thank you mr moyeton
mr lombards is next for one minute
madame president you are right
to uh note that you're a third the way
through your mandate not halfway despite
the pandemic
i would say that the easiest part has
been done that is starting on files and
present proposals now you need to put
your many
proposals in the environmental and
social field the rule of law and defense
democracy
while migration may be your bit less
ambitious there but all these proposals
need to be put in to practice and made
concrete now
and obviously
there will be some conflicts and
majorities will need to be found and you
need to do all you can to build
majorities and accept that there will be
people who don't want more financial
solidarity some people don't want more
climate action some people don't want
real action on the rule of law you'll
have to take that on board and build
majorities we need to be as inclusive as
possible yes but
we need your
you need you to help us construct
majorities thank you very much mr
lamberts
mr tullis is next for one minute
madam president you've heard
speakers
from
the union
what we expect now is action and i'm
fully aware that we need to do that
together you'll have
the support of our groups and the union
and i'm sure you'll have a majority here
in the parliament to implement what is
already on the table as quickly as
possible it's true that you still have
around three years of your mandate
to go so probably a year or so to table
new proposals
and then
put things into practice i heard your
message about the mechanism on rule of
law and i thank you for that i think
that's the signal that many were
expecting and waiting for because
the economy money and employment count
people expect a lot of that but it needs
to be built upon a solid basis and one
last word do not forget that
we
have committed together in the
conference to follow up on the
conclusions emerging from that
conference
we will be side by side with you
we
will be uh
waiting for those conclusions and then
commission proposals following on from
that people
expect and hope to see a better union
than the one they found
thank you mr churlos
mrs garcia perez is next for one minute
thank you it's difficult in one minute
to sum up the whole debate so if i may
i'll focus on one point i listen to the
extreme right in this house
saying that climate policy in the union
is responsible for the rising energy
prices please they couldn't be more
wrong
that's not the problem the problem for
the prices in energy prices
is that some people triple their profits
and it's citizens and users that have to
pay that
um what we should do
is actually
shore up fighting climate change through
the policies we're introducing but we
should also ensure
that
real energy costs on the market
are taken into account when calculating
the profits of energy companies
madame van der leyen i think we've
fought covered with
courage and courage is vital but not
just in moments of crisis courage is
vital to build a europe that will really
be by the sides of citizens
if you think that
that is the path we should take the
socialist and democrats group will be by
your side thank you
for calling
thank you very much mrs cicardia perez
and finally mr gonzalez ponce for one
minute
this is the last speech
you can count on the support of our
group
to face up to those difficult challenges
the digital transition
the ecological transition without
creating energy poverty the good news is
that parliament is back parliament is
here once again so european democracy is
here
whatever we do whichever way we go let's
all
bear in mind that what we need most of
all is to recover the european spirit
the european spirit let's create
that
once again in europe thank you there
fintank
thank you very much indeed mr gonzalez
ponce
so that concludes the debate
the sitting is suspended and will resume
at 3 p.m with the debate on the report
by mr gigold on implementation of eu
requirements for exchange of tax
information
we now adjourn
you